mal erkennen, Stream ist on
und, na, erst mal
Twitter, Twitter-Post hin.
Vielleicht soll ich den Titel
noch sowas reinschreiben, wie German
Stream oder sowas.
Vielleicht bringt das was.
Was
meint ihr Leute, falls schon jemand da ist?
Meint ihr, es ist sinnvoll, wenn ich irgendwie German
oder sowas oder DE
oder sonst irgendwie sowas in Titel schreibe?
Weil die ganzen
Noobs, also die, die noch
schlechter sind als ich,
die gucken ja immer nach
deutschen Streams.
Weißt du, das bringt was.
Ja, wir schreiben da noch
DE rein.
Mein Handy macht Geräusche.
Ja?
Mein Handy hat komische Geräusche gemacht.
Oder war das deins?
Ich weiß ja nicht, ob von
der einen Tischhälfte zur anderen rüber das
aufgenommen wird. Weißt du, es hat sich
angehört wie mein Handy, aber es war nicht meins, als ich jetzt
draufgeguckt habe. Es hat halt gerade vibriert.
War deins, oder?
Ja.
Hast du es auf dem Tisch stehen, dein Mikrofon?
Dann überträgt das ja.
Ja.
Das ist auch zwei, das ist Activation.
Ah ja, Tim Lampe, das ist eine gute Idee.
Keine Dings, keine Mikrofonspinne.
Ja, alles klar
bei mir. Moin, King Chris
und Tim Lampe.
Ja, ich mach noch Ger-Entitel.
Mercy mein Only-Stream
heute. Nein. Ich spiel nur
Mercy, wenn es gar nicht anders geht.
Äh, nein, wenn den Titel
mach ich, mach ich, mach ich vorne das so in
in eckigen Klammern.
Das macht der Kami auch immer.
Der weiß, was er macht.
Aber so. So, mal gucken,
ob er jetzt den Titel aktualisiert hat.
Äh.
Bei mir hat's den Titel nicht
aktualisiert. Warum aktualisiert's den Titel nicht, obwohl
ich den Titel ändere?
Äh, Moment. Das aktualisiert
den Titel nicht, obwohl ich den Titel ändere. Das ist natürlich
auch toll.
Äh.
Wobei,
hier, hier stimmt's jetzt.
DE.
Ah, nochmal F5 drücken.
Ja, jetzt stimmt's. Okay.
Twitch. Logik.
Aber allemal besser als auf YouTube
die Settings.
Ist mittlerweile so verhunzt.
Brauchst 30 Unermenüs und
50 Profilseiten, dass du das findest, was du suchst.
Was meinst du, ist
besser im Titel DE oder Ger?
Was, was
deutlich, äh, eindeutiger?
Wenn die Leute nach Deutsch
suchen, DE, hä?
Germanisch.
Germanisch? Das ist ja ein halber Titel weg.
Machen wir einfach mal so.
Ja, zack.
Easy. Easy clap.
Richtig. Emotions auch an.
Jawoll. Moin, Raffi.
Just so nikkutz.
Und die Ananas
und General Slain.
Auch da. Auf geht's.
Ich invite dich.
Mein Handy benachrichtigt, dass Leute
auf Twitter meine Posts liken.
Das macht's normalerweise nie.
Das sind dann meistens Leute, die viele Follower
haben. Da muss ich jetzt mal gucken.
Aha. Jemand von Twitch hat mein
mein Tweet geliked.
Oh mein Gott.
So, ähm, du würdest sagen,
legen wir mal los, ne?
Ich poste das jetzt noch. Ich such schon mal
Game. Wir müssen uns eh erstmal einspielen
wieder.
Alter. Ich hab
übelst kalte Hände. Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei dir ist,
aber erstmal zwei Runden.
Aufwärmen. Ich queue.
Ich poste das mal auf YouTube wieder.
Ja, bei mir ist es heute besser.
Ich glaube, YouTube hat nicht,
hat sich das anders vorgestellt.
Diese Posting-Funktion, anstatt
dass man damit seinen Twitch-Stream bewirbt.
Ich glaube, YouTube hatte damit
andere Sachen vor, ehrlich gesagt.
Also dieses
übliche, bla, keine Ahnung,
irgendwelche Umfragen oder
neue Video-Ankündigungen oder sonst was.
Aber meine letzten drei Posts auf YouTube,
Stream jetzt auf der Watchrank-Twitch.
Schaut vorbei.
Dann müsst ihr meinen Tweet
raushauen an YouTube.
Nein, bloß nicht.
Bloß nicht.
Ich glaube, das ist immer noch Experimental-Feature.
Dann deaktivieren sie das wieder.
Hast du es schon in T500 geschafft?
Nein, wir haben gestern Master gemacht mit 7 zu 2.
Muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Wir haben sieben Games gewonnen, zwei verloren.
Trotzdem gerade so Master.
Ähm, so.
So, bin wieder auf Twitch.
On, ne, schau mal, live mit Overworld.
Haben wir gestern echt nur zwei verloren?
Ranked.
Wir haben drei verloren, wenn man das,
ne, vier, vier verloren, wenn man das Aufwärmen mitzählt.
Beim Aufwärmen, die ersten zwei Matches,
wo wir, wo wir gesagt haben, ja, erst mal warmspielen,
haben wir, haben wir direkt auf den Sack gekriegt.
Ich dachte doch gerade, das kann mir ein bisschen mehr kommen.
Ne, ne, wir haben ein bisschen, wir haben ein bisschen mehr verloren.
Aber nachdem wir da erst eingespielt waren,
haben wir am Ende, haben wir sieben zu zwei.
Ja, ja.
Wobei, egal.
Ich hab ja eh mehr Punkte gemacht als Miese, ne.
Aber das ist richtig.
Ah, tipp, tipp, tipp.
Ich glaub, der Swerf ist jetzt auf so einem Hartz-Sack raus.
Ich, äh, picke mal gleich irgendwie irgendeine, das,
ich, ich, ich log erst mal rein, hat einen Swerf,
nur um mir sicher zu gehen, dass keiner irgendwelche komischen Dinger macht,
jetzt mit, dass ich wieder Master spielen muss.
Ansonsten, ich kann ja immer noch switchen.
Ähm, ich muss erst mal jetzt hier YouTube-Message losschicken.
Bin wieder live auf Twitch mit Overworld-Train.
Gestern wieder Master geparkt.
Endlich.
Endlich wieder, gestern.
Endlich wieder Master geparkt.
Beitrag erstellen.
Nice.
Das jetzt funktioniert?
Mich würd's nicht wundern, wenn die das bei YouTube wieder abschalten,
wenn sie feststellen, dass sich die Leute nur zum Promoten von anderen Zeiten benutzen.
Haben wir, äh, ist, ist in,
oh, meint das Overlay-Stip nicht,
ist ein Mod gerade am Start?
Eine der Mods am Start.
Jawoll, alle, die schon da sind, sind ganz schön früh am Start.
15.40 Uhr unter der Woche.
Was ist da los? Habt ihr Urlaub?
Sind schon Schulferien?
Also, Frage in die Runde.
Kriegt das dann immer richtig mit.
Du bist immer da, Mr. Fryguy.
Nice.
Oh, gehämmert.
Pschu!
Was? Die sind ausgewichen?
Was?
Ah, ist schon 25% Shatter.
Schild bricht gleich.
Ich muss weg.
Oh, nice, nice.
Weißt du, pushen, pusherino.
Go, go, go.
Ich baite mal, hock, ich baite mal, hock.
Ha, ha, ha, lull.
Noob, noob Roadhog.
Mercy war auch low.
Ja, ich geh immer nicht hinterher.
Lass das mal sicher durchpushen.
Wer weiß, sie falle um die Ecke, Junkrat spammt mich weg.
Contest denied.
Jetzt wird einer Flash sprayen.
Gibt nix.
Wir haben Goldenboy im Team.
Bestimmt der echte, Woodface.
Ach, Roadhog.
Du triffst da gar nix.
Ich will Shatter aufladen.
70.
Ha, ha, der Roadhog, damn it, she baited mit den Hooks.
Nein!
90 Shatter.
Äh, Junkrat.
Ist weg, ist weg, ist weg.
Passt.
Äh, oder auch nicht.
Wir verlieren das.
Wir kriegen auf den Sack.
Mal Shatter baiten.
Falls, falls er hat.
Wohoho, WTF.
Ich, ich, ich verpiss mich mal.
Rechts ist ein Roadhog, alleine.
Ich hab aber nur noch 600 Schild.
Ich hab Shatter am Schack.
Gleich, gleich, Leute.
Huge Shatter.
Huge Shatter kommt jetzt gleich.
Der, der müsste auch Shatter haben, der Reinhardt.
Ich baite das Ding mal.
Ich versuch.
Ah, Hook.
Wo kommt der Teil aus?
Ja, kann man nicht.
Fuck, Mann.
Oh, ich schliepe.
Pretty simple.
Puh.
Ne, da geht nix.
Free Hammer.
Haben wir ne Mercy?
Ach, wir haben keine Mercy, deswegen geht's nicht vorwärts.
No Mercy, no Win.
Leute, so ist das halt.
Also, der Roadhog lässt sich easy baiten.
Der Hook, ja.
Leckt.
Oh, der ist voll.
Lass mich mal, lass mich mal.
Ich bin auf.
Ich schlafe, der könnte shattern, klar.
Der muss shattern haben.
Nice, der Reinhardt ist down, wird gerätzt.
Der wird gleich shattern, 100 pro.
Ist aber down.
Wieder gerätzt.
The fuck?
Einfach pushen.
Progress machen.
Was ist denn hier los? Über mir, über mir.
Kann ich leider nicht wegmachen.
Wir müssen ein bisschen mehr zusammenstehen.
Und wir brauchen eine Mercy.
Eine Mercy, no win.
Ich glaube, ich gehe gleich Winston.
Wir haben nichts zu melden auf dem Highground.
Aktuell, gar nichts.
Pass auf, du bist alleine vorne.
Nein, er hat mich eingeklemmt.
Schild bricht.
Der Roadhog lässt sich aber echt easy baiten.
Ich habe gleich wieder Shatter am Start.
Highground ist clear.
Das sind 30 Milliarden Gegner.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich was erwischt habe.
Ich habe den Roadhog.
Nein, ich schlafe, ich schlafe.
Puh.
Haben wir eine Mercy mittlerweile?
Ich nehme mal wieder, das könnte mal funktionieren.
Ich nehme mal ein bisschen was mobileres.
Huge Shatter war das gerade wieder.
Schöne Chill.
Aber es geht nicht wirklich vorwärts.
Kannst du aufs Dach hoch?
Oh, ey.
Die Matrix ist leer.
Ich bleibe auf dem Dach.
Der Junkrat spammt.
Sag, wenn ihr unten wieder am Start seid, dann komme ich raus.
Oh, das ganze Dach ist voll.
Die stehen alle auf dem Dach.
Nice, nice.
Ich gehe rein.
Der McCree fällt zurück.
Wo kommt jetzt der Junkrat her?
Okay, Roadhog ist weg.
McCree ist noch oben.
Ja.
Hinter euch.
Okay.
Ziehen wir durch.
Ja, habe ich nicht gesehen.
Ah, so gesagt.
Ich gucke gleich in den Chat, Leute.
Erstmal die Runde jetzt.
Ich gewinne.
Der Roadhog, will der flanken oder was ist mit dem los?
Kannst du mich ruhig rücken, Roadhog?
Habe ich nichts dagegen.
Der ist low, der ist low.
Kein Wahnlauf.
Klein, hilf mir.
Ah.
Oh Gott.
Wo ist das Tire?
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe ihn.
Die Mercy, die Mercy retzt.
Nein.
4% vor Ulti.
Fuck.
Sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr gut.
Der YOLO-Smurf ist down.
Ich brauche mal ein Auto wieder.
Ist weg.
Irgendwas ist rechts.
Irgendwas habe ich rechts noch gehört.
Gleich wieder Auto.
Fuck.
Das war zu viel.
Der Retz rettet den.
Sowas von den Arsch hier.
Das war.
Recoup.
Ob es später noch ein Team, äh, ein Group chat.
Ich fliege da gleich dran.
Ich fliege da gleich dran und Ulte.
Boah, nichts getroffen.
Fuck.
Von hinten, von hinten.
Ja.
Zarya ist fast down.
Ich bin dran, ich bin dran.
Na ja, kriegt man nicht.
No Mercy, no win.
Boah.
Jetzt haben sie aber übertrieben.
Lul.
Ich meine, das können wir defenden.
Das geht, weil wir das gut machen.
Das ist auf jeden Fall zu gewinnen.
Erst mal Cross verändern.
So, ich muss mal, ich mute mich mal hier Discord kurz und muss mal Chat gucken.
So.
Was habe ich denn hier im Chat übersehen?
Top 500?
Nein.
Bei weitem nicht.
Gestern erst mal war Master wieder.
Ich habe ja seit Season 3 nicht gespielt.
Ja.
Morris 3500.
Gestern erst mal war Master wieder.
Ich habe ja seit Season 3 nicht gespielt.
Gestern erreicht.
3520.
Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt verlieren, steigen wir gleich wieder ab.
Soll ich Mercy picken?
Nein.
Ah, oder?
Doch, komm.
Jetzt hier.
Passt mal auf.
Huge Mercy Plays, Leute.
Huge Mercy Plays.
Ja.
Neue Mercy.
Mercy Main.
So, was habe ich noch überlesen?
Wann gibt es wieder Battlefield 3?
Es gab letztens einen Battlefield 3 Stream.
Oh, geil.
Vor ein paar Tagen.
Gar nicht so lange.
Hier.
Ich finde das schon ein bisschen witzig.
Weil, eigentlich hat ja Mercy, so gesehen, den Platz von Symmetra genommen, ne?
Den nützlichen TP zu nutzen, so.
Stimmt, ja.
Ah, ich muss gerade noch mal kurz Chat lesen.
Ich habe viel verpasst.
Ey, Max, Navi hängt's.
Ich bin ja nicht Münzen.
Heute nur 9 bis 10.
Ah, das, okay.
9 bis 10.
9 bis 12.
Nice.
9 bis 12 Schule und dann Schluss.
So.
Ich muss jetzt erst mal wieder vorlaufen.
Bin ich dann mal rechtzeitig da.
Ui.
Ich lese gleich weiter, Chat.
Oh, fuck, Winston.
Da habe ich jetzt ja gar keinen Bock drauf.
Und ein Ge...
Oh, fuck.
Das ist...
Ich...
Ich werde hier echt Probleme haben, klar.
Mit Winston und Genji.
Die haben es voll auf mich abgesehen.
Ich damage booste dich mal.
Na, Genji, von links.
Von links.
Auf unsere Ana.
Die...
Der weiß auf jeden Fall, wo ich bin.
Ich bin da.
Du...
Du kriegst Boost?
Ja, ich sehe bloß gerade nichts.
Diva...
Diva dahinter uns.
Wir müssen runter.
Leute, wir müssen runter.
Droped.
Winston ist hochgesprungen.
Das heißt, er jetzt erstmal hat keinen Jump.
Gehe ich gleich drauf.
Nope.
Die Jana könnte ich ja auch mal heilen, ne?
Das wäre ja auch mal ein Bereich des Möglichen.
Ich verstecke mich mal in der Ecke.
Sagt mir, wenn ihr daneben Hilfe braucht.
90% D.Va flankt. Wir müssen jetzt bloß gucken, dass sie nicht durchpusht in der Zeit, wo wir hier Flank und Reno machen.
Gleich Ulti, gleich Ulti. 1% noch.
Nice!
Damage Boost.
Das war nur ein Reinhard.
Sag mal was du siehst. Ich trau mich nicht raus zu gucken gegen Genji und Winston.
Ne, die haben geswitcht. WTF.
Aber eine D.Va haben sie jetzt.
Ok, ich geh runter.
Ich geh mal runter.
Ah nein.
Ich hab dich.
Die pushen durch.
Der Kree ist links durch.
Ja, ich muss ein bisschen aufpassen.
Wo ist hier was gestorben gerade? Ist schon was gestorben?
Wo ist der Hochhallen?
Es ist auch die Mercy abend frühstücken und gut ist.
Ja, die D.Va ist halt rechts hinter uns noch.
Was ist hier?
Da ist was im Marktstand hier.
Irgendwo.
Ja.
Wo steckst du?
Suchst du die?
Oh fuck, fuck, fuck. Unsere Ana kriegt aufs Maul.
Komm raus.
Ich versuch's zu retzen.
Fuck, fuck, fuck. Ich krieg von hinten, von hinten. Die D.Va hinter mir.
Ne.
Schön gedeift.
Gute Zeit.
Richtig gute Zeit.
Magst du die jetzt? Gut.
Wieder Master.
Nach 6 Monaten nicht spielen.
Dank Eaks Carry. Alles kein Ding.
Wir können doch mal contesten.
Ja, wenn du schnell machst.
Einer von euch muss ran, der andere geht ran.
Okay, nice. Ich bin da. Die sind nämlich auch nicht dran.
Gucken, vielleicht kriegst du einen schönen Pick.
D.Va rechts. D.Va flankt rechts. Achtung.
Ich bleib auf dir mit Damage Boost. Aber die D.Va kommt gleich wieder um die Ecke. Ja, ja, die ist rechts. Da schon.
Nice Pick. Sehr, sehr nice Pick.
Nice Defense.
Oben die Mercy.
Murky.
Ach, Reinhard, na komm.
Ich bitte dich.
Nice. So, so, so kann's weitergehen, oder?
Hoffentlich nicht, ey.
Sind wir fast GM?
Meine Hände sind immer übelst kalt.
So, jetzt muss ich mal Chat gucken. Ich mut mich Discord noch mal kurz.
So, was hab ich verpasst hier, Chat?
Ähm.
Twitch schauen mehr Studenten, YouTube schauen mehr Schüler.
Das, äh, weiß nicht.
Da, hast du da eine Statistik zu?
Ich glaub, ich glaub sowohl YouTube als auch Twitch schauen alle.
Twitch vielleicht weniger.
Sagen wir so, ich glaub bei den älteren Leuten, sagen wir so, irgendwie so 40 plus oder so.
40, 45 plus, die, glaube ich, schauen eher YouTube als Twitch.
Sogar Rentner schauen YouTube, aber die schauen wahrscheinlich eher kein Twitch.
Hampi, moin.
Das erste Mal da, schaue seit Jahren deine Videos.
Das ist doch nice.
Keyform ist auch am Start.
No Second Plan ist auch wieder da.
Max, machst du auf deinem Smurf auch 6er Viewer ranked?
Äh.
Naja, das ist ja gar nicht so wirklich mein Smurf.
Mein Main Account ist seit Season 3 eigentlich gerankt.
Und das interne Matchmaking ist einfach viel zu hoch für mich.
Ähm.
Gestern nur am Gewinnen, heute nur am Verlieren.
Ja, das ist doof, Hero.
Aber, statistisch gesehen...
Ja, ich cure.
Aber, statistisch gesehen, wenn du lange nur spielst, gleicht sich das wieder aus, auch wenn es mega frustrierend ist.
Am besten ist, du hörst auf.
Wenn es dir so auf den Sack geht, dass du gar keinen Bock mehr hast, weiter zu spielen, ist es am besten, du machst mal Pause.
Solo-Cue ist echt eine Qual.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Deswegen gebe ich mir auch Solo-Cue nicht und wir spielen zu zweit.
Hattest du nicht vor einer Zeit mal keinen Bock mehr auf Overwatch?
Ja.
Aber Solo hätte ich auch keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Aber zu zweit ist das wirklich ganz spaßig.
Das hält sich so ein bisschen die Waage, weißt du?
Da kann man sich dann immer noch so ein bisschen gegenseitig gut zureden, so.
Max, hast du eine mechanische Tastatur?
Nein.
Aber ich muss mir demnächst mal eine neue holen.
Ich finde es immer merkwürdig, wie er Callout fürs Team gibt, aber nur mit Eax redet.
Ja, das ist auch erstmal der Wichtigste, der es hören muss.
Was nimmt Eax für einen Carry?
Ich kann ihn ja mal fragen.
Max, wie viel nimmst du für Carrying auf Master Plus?
Fragt der Chat.
Auf Master Plus?
Ja.
Wie viel willst du?
Also die Salt-Zulage, die Frust-Zulage, die Depression, die Tabletten, die ich dafür
brauche.
Das wird teuer, oder?
Ja.
Wird heftig teuer.
Brauchen wir Support?
Komm, wir spielen Support.
Komm, wir machen jetzt mal hier das krasse Healer-Duo.
Soll ich Anna spielen?
Oder was willst du denn haben als zweiten Support?
Speed, oder?
Speed.
Ja.
Speed, hä?
Also mir ist es egal, was du willst.
Risa bringt Speed ja gerade nichts.
Speed bringt immer was.
Wobei, naja.
Kommst du mit Zen klar?
Ja.
Ansonsten nehme ich Zen.
So, TH ist da.
Hi.
Moin.
Von Support, DD und Tank, was spielst du am wenigsten?
DD.
DPS spiele ich kaum.
Ab und zu mal Soldier.
Na gut, ich meine Reaper.
Zielen und klicken.
Aber ich spiele nicht mit.
Ich spiele die ganze DPS-Sparte mit Abstand am wenigsten.
Ich spiele eigentlich hauptsächlich die hier.
So.
Diese Ecke.
Leute, was ist denn dieses komische Symbol oben links, was manchmal aufploppt?
Dieser Blitz.
Das Reload-Symbol und der Blitz.
Ist das Packet lost, oder ist das Server lag, oder was ist das?
Oh, jetzt bin ich Zen, jetzt muss ich aufpassen.
Also von Reinhard auf Zen-Switch ist wirklich schwierig.
Genji, du kriegst einen Heal-Orb.
Nope, kriegst du nicht.
Ich spamme Schild, die Orisa ist ziemlich low on point.
Achso, ne Backline.
Das geht auf mich, da geht keiner so wirklich drauf.
Orisa ist weg.
Fuck, ich hätte ihn heilen sollen.
Die haben nur Widow, oder?
Irgendwas hat mich gesniped von hinten, oder fast gesniped.
Der hat nicht mal viel, der Genji.
Rekt, was?
Was hat der überlebt?
Da, fuck.
Genji ist wieder da.
Nice, du.
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
Spamme mal Schild, ich spamme mal Schild.
Die Orisa-Attack sackt halt auch mal richtig, so.
Ich bin down.
Ich habe aber gleich Ulti.
Ich hab gleich Ulti, fünf Prozent.
Oh, huge res, huge res.
Wir gehen da gleich mit Ulti rein.
Ich mach noch einen Kill, dann gehen wir mit Ulti rein.
Komm Genji, geh rein.
Geh rein.
Gengu, go, go.
Moved euch.
Damage boost.
um ob ich hab mich gehört hat mich geholfen
ja anders was dauern
denn sie auch fast tot
als ein Schulte Mörsi
Marki ob ich mich treffe
das ist ein Playtest
ich greife ein bisschen viel
Schatz ab
wir müssen auf die Minikraft aufpassen
auch Winston
ich hab gleich wieder Ulti
geht übelst ab
wieder Ulti am Start
ich push weiter, ich push mit der Orisa, sind sonst zu wenig dran
falls ich vorkommen soll, sagt, oder wenn ihr gewiped werdet, ich kann ulten
sagt bloß rechtzeitig Bescheid
wir sind gleich durch
das NA muss ich wieder ein bisschen üben
oh, es ist keiner am Payload
ich bin dran
fuck, bisschen, Tick hin zu spät
Tick hin zu spät
Huge Razz
Mekri
du hast einen Orb drauf
Genji ist Discorded
Achievement unlocked
mach den Reinhardt kaputt
weg Dorino
Huge Razz, der hat Shatter
der guckt schon so
der Shattert mich, mit seinen Augen Shattert er mich schon
ich alles
mach platt
komm, hier, Reinhardt
bald haben wir verloren
direkt
ha, gute Zeit
60 Prozent Ult
Claus Tchaikovsky
die fressen mega Damages
ваши Huge Razz
es war Kinder
es 6
das Gegenteil von Huge Press.
Aber das war ein nice Stand Place.
Also, der ist auch
übelst geil.
Das ist eines meiner Lieblings-Supporter oder generell
meiner Lieblings-Helden.
Kann sie die Gegner halt so
recken. Wollen wir mal
Anna Mercy machen oder? Komm, wir warten mal, was die
picken. Moin,
Matti,
Akamu,
einfach Picks.
Dovenji, ja, hab ich. Er hat gefragt,
hey Max, hast du auch ein Nahrungsmittel, das du als
Kind gar nicht mochtest und jetzt überdurchschnittlich magst?
Rote Beete.
Ähm, huge Anna Place.
Ich muss mal meinen Stream
selbst mal hier auf Pause machen.
Muss mir jetzt ja nicht auf dem zweiten Monitor noch angucken.
Rote Beete fand ich eklig.
Meine Oma hat das immer gemacht, wie ich klein war.
Hab ich auch gesagt, äh, Oma, kannst
mal nicht was anderes machen? Genauso, die Oma
hat auch zu Silvester,
glaube ich, war das, oder was war das? Ich weiß gar nicht,
war immer irgendwie Zunge
von irgendeinem Viech gemacht. Ey, oh, übelst
eklig, mittlerweile schmeckt's mir.
Moment kurz, ich muss mich kurz vermuten.
Einer hat an der Tür geklopft, traut sich,
damit reinzukommen.
Ha, jetzt werden sie gereckt.
Ich versteck mich schon ein bisschen,
falls die da rumschneipern.
Oh, der McCree ist fast tot.
Wo schießt denn der Junk eigentlich hin?
Ich weiß nicht. Er macht keinen einzigen Hitmarker.
Ich weiß nicht. Ich glaub, die haben schon
den Hardcore-Tilty-Gegner wieder.
Ich lieb dich, sag ich.
Na ja, du wirst jetzt gesleept.
Sleep, sleep, huge sleep.
Äh, Tracer links. Tracer, linke Seite.
Ah, auf, mir drauf. Irgendwas von hinten.
Ich weiß nicht, war's ein McCree?
Das war One-Clip.
Die hat mich, die hat mich
One-Clipped.
One-Clip.
Kommst du zurück? Ja.
Wollt nochmal auf die Ecke gucken.
Da kommt schon McCree.
Sleeped, der Sleeped, der Sleeped, der Sleeped.
Ich nade den.
Jawoll.
Rekt.
Rektangled.
Tyrannosaurus rekt.
Lowtalk, du bist viel zu weit vorne.
Tracer ist rechts in der Bibliothek drin.
Oh, huge. Jetzt können wir pushen.
Was macht der da oben?
Sleeped, sleeped, sleeped.
Hat sich ausgesleeped.
Könnte er eigentlich voll gut pushen jetzt.
Will aber keiner.
Genji ist auch drin.
Oh, fuck.
Verpiss dich, harambe.
Never forget.
Sleeped, sleeped, sleeped, sleeped, sleeped.
Hinter euch.
Wolltest du hinter euch.
Oh, oh.
Ich steh da ganz schön kacke drin.
Huge Razz.
Da sind wir noch.
Schön die Lane.
Zeit holen.
Muss sein.
Die Zeit ist noch zu gut.
Wir müssen auf jeden Fall nochmal contesten jetzt.
Ich wunder, dass wir haben eigentlich die übelste Spam-Combo, aber wir haben kein Damage.
Ist schwierig.
Ja, ja.
Und wir pushen auch nicht, wenn wir pushen können.
Wir hätten die zweimal super vipen können.
So, Leute.
Rein jetzt da.
Wir haben kein...
Doch, wir haben ein Schild.
Auf Orisa.
Wenn wir Nanoboost, ist eigentlich am besten.
Rechts, rechts die Tracer.
Komm, ich Nanoboost jetzt die Orisa.
Irgendwas.
Jetzt wie beim Junk machen, so.
In der Hoffnung, dass das das wird, natürlich.
Muss weg.
Huge Razz.
Ist der tot, der McQueen?
Ja.
Purple.
Dass wir hier nicht backcapped werden.
Oh, Achtung, da ist ein Fahrer in der Mitte.
Da sollten wir jetzt nicht hin.
Das recommande ich auch, Orisa.
Leute, ist der Gamesound okay, oder zu leise?
Oh, links Tracer neben mir.
Komm, die hacken wir jetzt.
Ich hab keine Granate da.
Zack, zack, bist du ohne aus.
Entschuldigung.
Ich bin heal auf dir.
Okay.
Man weiß ja nie.
Die will rechts flanken.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ich hab ne Rakete abge...
Ah!
Oh, Gott.
Puh.
Nice.
Huge, huge Razz.
Schläft.
Fahrer, Fahrer von hinten irgendwo.
Über uns.
Ohne Tracer.
Nice.
Das haben wir schön gestallt jetzt.
Gleich wieder Nanoboost.
Leider etwas leise.
Ich mach Gamesound, kann ich nach der Runde lauter machen.
Ticken.
Wenn ihr wollt.
Kann ich nach der Runde machen.
Oh, Roadhog.
Übertreib's nicht.
Ich dachte, er hat Ulti und kann die wegspammen.
Ja, kann er doch.
Macht doch Roadhog.
Nice.
Nein.
Fuck.
Zeit ist top.
Mit Kopfhörer ist der Sound perfekt.
Na gut, dann kann ich es auch so lassen.
Kriegen wir es, kriegen wir es nochmal?
Nein.
Oh, der hat immer noch nen Healscan, ne?
Nevermind.
Stunt macht schon.
Der macht das.
Der Healscant.
Ja.
Der AR stands.
Ins Gesicht fliegen und dann..
..und Scannen!
Dann ist das auch Heal Scan beim lànken.
Area Scan.
Mercy ist fast down, Mercysemone.
Ich versuche ne Granate hinterherzuhauen.
Oh, ja...
so knapp.
Ich hab ihn
Rechts
Soldier, wie sie aussieht jetzt
Vielleicht sollten wir nicht ganz so übertrieben weit vorne halten
Äh, doch, geht schon
Also nur 35 Sekunden
Soldier bei mir hinten
Soldier bei mir
Boah, die werden aber gereckt, ey
Die Diva will auf mich
Ich hab Schiss
Was? Moment, Chat
Chat, warum hat mich die Granate nicht geheilt?
Ich hab eine Granate auf meine Füße geworfen
Die nichts gemacht hat
Please explain
Warum hat mich das nicht geheilt gerade?
Die kann durch den Spalt
Da ist ein Spalt in der Erde
WTF
Das ist so ein Spalt, den man nicht
Wenn man ihn treffen will, trifft man ihn nicht
Und wenn man ihn nicht treffen will, dann wirft man aus Versehen rein
Ah, gut
Bist du aufgewärmt?
Äh
Ja, die Wins kannst du ja dazu eintragen
Ist ja nicht das Ding
Stimmt
Eigentlich kann ich da eintragen
Ähm
Ja, da kann ich ein bisschen Chat gucken
Oh nein, ist gleich alles schön geklippt
Das muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken
Und dann warten wir mal
Wir gucken uns das jetzt mal kurz zusammen auf Stream an
Also da ist mal
Display Capture
Das nervt mich in OBS immer ein bisschen
Jetzt gucken wir mal
Ich hab Schiss
Alter
Nee, oder?
Ich hab Schiss
Oh Gott
Ich glaub's nicht
Was?
Moment
Chat, Chat
Warum hat mich die Granate nicht
Ja, gut
Shit happens, ne?
Shit happens
Ist dein Duo-Pate ein Real-Life-Kollege oder hast du ihn im Internet kennengelernt?
Äh, Eax ist ein ehemaliges Overwatch-Teamate aus unserer, ganz am Anfang von Overwatch aus
unserem Szenen
Wo wir auch ein paar Cups mitgespielt haben
Und eigentlich ganz gut dabei waren
Der TH auch, der vorhin im Chat war
Und wir haben uns gedacht, es ist mal wieder Zeit Overwatch rauszuholen
Nachdem's ihn übelst getiltet hat Solo zu spielen und mich
Haben wir gedacht, komm wir duo-queuen jetzt einfach ordentlich
Und seitdem macht das auch wieder viel mehr Spaß
Das kann ich auch nur jedem empfehlen
Jeden, den das anpisst
Ähm
Solo zu spielen
Duo ist gleich mal ne ganze Ecke entspannter
Die ganzen U-Zeichen bei der Heldengalerie triggern
Ich hab in der Heldengalerie noch nichts eingestellt
Noch gar nix
Wir machen jetzt Lootbox auf
Nichts Goldenes
Nein, jetzt was Goldenes
Irgendwas Goldenes für irgendeinen Held, den ich spiele
Hä?
Bääääh
Nein
Spiel ich nicht
Aber okay, Währung ist nicht schlecht
Kommen wir uns irgendwie...
Was, was, was könnten wir mal machen?
Wir könnten uns nen Reinhardt-Skin, nen Zen-Skin, nen Mercy-Skin
Was können wir uns denn jetzt mal holen?
Mal holen wir uns garantiert nicht
Roadhog
Aber die coolen Skins kosten halt mehr, ne?
Was gibt's denn für Reinhardt-Skins?
Die nicht so viel kosten
Tausend, tausend
Der ist nice
Ne, Bundeswehr
Bundeswehr wird unlockt, Bundeswehr Reinhardt
Habe ich einen ordentlichen Skin dran
Ähm
Kurz Wortfragen
Planst du wieder ein Sechser-Team zusammenzustellen?
Nö
Wenn man sich jetzt überlegt
Von welchem Kaliber die Teams aktuell sind
Um da auch nur halbwegs wieder dranzukommen
Erstens traue ich mir das selbst nicht zu, mittlerweile
Da wieder wirklich mitzuspielen
Und du müsstest ja quasi noch weitere Leute finden
Und dann müsstest du jeden Tag, oder spielst du jeden Tag
Zweiten Tag, fünf, sechs Stunden
Riten und üben
Da habe ich keine Zeit für
Ich spiele das Ganze casual-mäßig
Das reicht mir
Bisschen Duo-Q-Ranked
Und wenn sie das Ranking-System verbessern, umso besser
Und wenn es irgendwann mal eine Team-Q geben sollte
Also irgendwas, wo man dann auch wirklich gegen andere Teams auf ähnlichem, ähm, Rank spielt
Dann kann man sich das wieder überlegen
Es ist, wie gesagt, ich habe es in jedem Stream, glaube ich, gesagt jetzt
Dass ich es irgendwie ein bisschen absurd finde, dass es gerade in Overwatch, wo auch der Hersteller selbst sagt
Ähm
Das ist ein Teamspiel, dass es eben keine Team-Q gibt
Ich verstehe das nicht, warum?
Warum?
Warum gibt es keine Team-Q?
Yo, hab einen Smurf auf Master, kann ich mit-Q?
Ne, gerade nicht, wir bleiben erstmal Duo
Wir wieder da, kannst kommen
Ja, ich Q
MrFryger, mehr Lootboxen, soll ich mehr Lootboxen aufmachen?
Wollt ihr mehr Lootboxen?
Erinnern euch das da nicht so sehr an Battlefront oder sowas?
Ich kann, wenn ihr wollt, kann ich nächste, nach der Runde, mache ich alle Lootboxen auf
Was ist Gifts im Menü?
Auf dem neuen Gifts im Menü kannst du die Hearthstone-Kartenpacks kaufen
Warum auch immer man das in Overwatch machen sollte?
Keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht
Ich schau mal, was die anderen picken
Uni-Smurf
Wirklich? Bestimmt Genji-Main, hä?
Natürlich
Kann ja nicht anders sein
Ja, 7 Stunden
Uni-Smurf
Na, wenn der Genji-Main ist, dann können wir Winston grillen
Gucken wir mal
Moment
Was ist denn das?
Haben wir wieder so einen geilen Symmetra-Thrower im Team?
Wir müssen, glaube ich, irgendwann mal noch einen Torb- und Symmetra-Main-Counter machen
Im Stream
Hat geswitcht, okay
Max, was hältst du von Battlefront 2? Ich nicht, ich nix
Der Eax hat es ein bisschen gespielt, du fandst es ganz gut, ne?
Ja, wenn man die Tilt-Sachen auslässt, ne?
Sowas hatte ich bei Battlefront 2 getiltet
Ja, warte mal
Die Helden?
Die Lootboxen
Ja
Komplette Charakter-Unlock, ne? Du brauchst Joy-Kappen
Das musst du ignorieren, dann macht das Spiel Spaß
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es mittlerweile wieder drin ist
Oh, hier ist ein Turret
Kannst du hoch gehen? Oben ist ein Turret
Wo oben?
Über dir
Da
Der Genji hat ordentlich Damage gefressen
Ich geh da gleich rein, sobald ich wieder Heal hab
Bumm
Oh, fuck, fuck, fuck, ich krieg Damage, ich krieg übelst Damage
Fuck
Ich hatte die Auswahl zwischen Torb, Shotgun und Turret
Ja, das war kacke
Ich hätte nicht auf den Spot gesoltert, sondern dem Genji hinterher
Aber wenn wir schnell sind
Nice, nice Pick, nice Pick
Ich bin gleich wieder da
Ne
Aber wir sind schneller wieder da
Ich bin schlechter, Winston
Leute, lasst euch nicht picken
Lasst euch nicht picken
Lasst euch nicht picken, gebt ihm keinen Charge und nix
Einfach wieder rein jetzt
Fein low
Ich brauch Hilfe
Nice
Ich bin down
Fuck, der Torb ist hinten rechts drinnen
Nice Picks
Das ist ultra nice Picks
Ich bleib jetzt noch auf Winston und hau Ult raus gleich
Auf den nächsten Punkten, wenn das nicht funktioniert
Switch ich
Ich muss schon noch ein bisschen üben
Die kommen wieder
Molten Core und so
Oh, ich bin gesleapt, fuck
Warum sind denn die eigentlich alle wieder da gerade?
Wie sind die so schnell wieder hergekommen?
Keine Ahnung, weil mir was leicht aus
Die waren auf einmal wieder da?
Das geht eigentlich gar nicht so schnell
So, ich bleib nochmal
Den Attack bleib ich nochmal auf Winston
Warum zum Teufel hast du den Account wo bloß?
Weil das ursprünglich nen...
Na, kein Fake Account, nen...
Undercover Account gewesen ist
Fuck
Okay, go go
Ich bin auf dem Punkt
Unten rechts ist die Sompra
Gleich kommt ne Sompra auf den Punkt
Ich seh sie bloß nicht
Ja, okay
So kanns auch gehen, ja
Hm, zum Glück
Trinkst du eigentlich Energydrinks
Oder hältst du nicht so viel davon?
Ich trinke keine Energydrinks
Aber ich halte auch jetzt nicht
Weder viel noch wenig von
Ist toll jeder trinken, wenn ihm das irgendwie...
Was hilft
Ich trinke aber auch keinen Kaffee oder ganz selten Kaffee
Ähm...
Ich würd fast...
Die spielen 100 pro wieder Genji
100 pro
Das sind nämlich beide die Typen, die da...
Dieser KFC und da ohne
Beides Genji-Mains
Oder soll ich zweitens was...
Was spielt denn dieser Warts...
Oh, wir haben zwei Mercy-Mains!
Wartsit und Crystal
Wo sind die Mercy-Mains, wenn man sie braucht, ne?
Jetzt haben wir sie doppelt
Moin Plops
Tracer
Der wird wahrscheinlich gelivet
Hast du gesehen? Bei denen?
Ne, ne, ich hör's ja schon
Ja, dann spielen die Tracer Genji
Die anderen spielen definitiv Genji
Genji
Nanzo ist dabei
Der ist links durch
Ach komm ey
Wenn der McFreezer mal den Nanzo abschießt
Schild ist kaputt
Ich block das Tor, ihr müsst hier hinten platt machen
Habt ihr sie platt?
Schild ist wieder kaputt
Hanzo, Hanzo ist da
Ich brauch Heal
Ich verpiss mich mal und lad Schild
Tja...
Oh, Sen, perfektes Timing
Gerade wo ich verrückt bin
Ich bin so weit vom Earthshatter weg
Was könnt ihr denn gegen die gescheit picken?
Ich hab das Gefühl, mit Reinhardt geht da nicht so viel
Weil die jetzt nicht so gespamme am Start haben
Ja, nimm mal Winston
Hanzo, Tracer, Soldier, er...
Hallo Shagger
Linke Seite
Soldier ist tot
Hanzo ist rechts, wieder an der Tür
Reinhardt kommt hoch
Wat?
Die Zarya ist noch unten, das passt
Die hat nicht mehr viel
Soldier in der Mitte, so nur
Geh mal auf den Soldier in der Mitte
Jupp
Ich bin halt relativ low
Ich bleib auf dem Spot stehen
Die Ana hat nicht mehr viel
Ich bin auf dem Spot, Soldier...
Soldier haut ab, Soldier ist abgehauen
Ah, fuck
Oben der Hanzo
Hanzo
Pass auf, Sen
Siehst du die Ana, die unten, solo?
Ich bin links in der Öffnung drin
Ja, ja, ich seh sie unter uns
Die kommen hoch
Reinhardt, Reinhardt ist ziemlich isoliert unten
Bank in der Mitte
Ich hab den Soldier
Der Soldier ist runtergenockt
Er macht erstmal nix mehr
Reinhardt oben
So, down
Soldier steht Main
Den können wir chasen
Na?
Können wir?
Ne, können wir nicht, zu viele
Hätten wir können
Oh, ich schlafe, fuck
Ich bin geschlitzt
Der Genji ist nach oben
Und der Soldier
Oh, geht auf den Punkt
Icepick, Icepick
Ich bin auf dem Punkt
Sonst keiner da
Ich bin zu dumm zum springen
Kein Hammerdown mehr
Ey, die sind so weit weg, man
Mit diesem ganzen Damage Drop
Das wird doch richtig beschissen
Ich bin über denen
Wenn sie unten reinkommen sollten
Wohin ist es unter euch?
Wo ist der Gengu?
Oh, ich bin gesleept, fuck
Oh, ich bin wieder da
Wie ich Mercy hasse
Kackheld, ey
Greudiger Kackheld
Zurück
Tracer
Rechtsseiter
Eisho, reisho, reisho
Ist irgendwas auf der linken Seite
Irgendwas solo
Vielleicht beim Medpack
McCree ist da
Und ein Rortok, die kommen jetzt rein
Null
Ich brauche noch 4 bis Schild
Haben alle gerätzt
Oh, oh, oh, ich bin geflasht, fuck
Jetzt haben sie mich geraped
Die Mercy steht direkt neben euch
Oh, huge res
Sniper, Sniper
Auf der anderen Seite
Äh, auch gut
Nichts los hier im Chat, oder wie?
Die sind alle so gefesselt vom Gameplay
Egal
Krassen Wilson-Plays
Wo sind sie denn?
Ich lauf dir nicht hinterher, McCree
Easy win
Was hältst du von Sombra in Ranked auf ganz speziellen Punkten?
Gut
Also man kann sie zum Beispiel auf
Wolfs-Gaia
oder so Defense einsetzen
Kannst du dir mal die
Du könntest, also wenn du coole Sombra-Plays sehen willst
Kannst du dir auf Twitch
Den Stream von Chipshine angucken
Sombra Games, die es in der Overwatch League gab. Dallas Fuel gegen, ich glaube, das letzte
Dallas Fuel Game. Die haben wir ganz schön gereckt, würde ich sagen. Ich muss mal kurz
aufs Klo. Ich bin gleich wieder da. Ich bin auch kurz zwei Minuten weg. So, gleich wieder
da. Wieder mal am Start. Ich habe irgendwas überlesen im Chat. Aber ich habe es angekündigt
heute. Winning Stream 3-0 Eats. Das war aber wirklich verhältnismäßig wenig im Chat
los. Das habe ich alle so geschafft. Wer mir noch nicht followt auf Twitch, kann das natürlich
gerne machen. Und ihr könnt auch mal auf YouTube vorbeigucken und natürlich auch auf
Twitter. Ich muss ja mal ein bisschen Sellout machen ab und zu. Falls mich jemand nicht
von YouTube kennt, das ist eigentlich so die Plattform, wo ich ursprünglich herkomme.
Es gibt seit 2010 Videos zu aktuellen Themen aus dem Gaming-Bereich.
Und so alles drumherum. Über, ich glaube, 800 Videos mittlerweile. Also ist schon ein
bisschen was. Es ist genug Content da. Es ist bestimmt auch das eine oder andere für
euch dabei. Ein Milchmensch fragt, hast du noch dein Pro-Klo? Klar habe ich das noch.
Es war ja auch teuer. Baby. Es war ja auch teuer, das Klo. Warum sollte ich das wegschmeißen?
Sag mal, wenn du ready bist. Ich bin schon ready. Du bist ready? Auf geht's.
Mach mal wieder ein Garten-Video. Hero-LP, hast du mal vor zwei Tagen auf den Channel geguckt?
Oh, wir haben Kami fast eingeholt. Also ich glaube, ich habe ihn überholt mittlerweile.
Ja? Ja. Was ist denn das? Brunnen. Brunnen. Ich glaube, ich glaube, warte mal, ich gucke mal, ob wir schon eine Mercy-Main haben.
Ja, Nicely. Nicely. Nicely hat es Mercy-Main. Mit 20 Stunden. Bam.
Win-Rate? 54. Easy. Easy Carry.
Käfer, was ist denn das für eine bescheuerte Frage?
Zeig mal her, was haben wir denn hier eigentlich jetzt für eine...
Das geht. Orisa ist ja cool, wenn man das drauf hat mit diesem Minicraft, kann es Leute in den Brunnen ziehen.
Team-Voice, please. Ja, komm, bevor er tiltet, ich gehe mal Team-Voice, dann freut er sich.
Ja, Hero-LP, ich habe ein Garten-Video.
Sag ich doch.
Check, ich blick nicht durch.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Keine Güte, treff mal was, Reax, treff was.
Kalla ist fast down. Ach, fuck. Aber auch nur fast.
Ich hänge drinnen.
Ich bin raus, ich bin raus.
Was?
Oh, der Lucio, nice play.
Was muss man sagen?
Da kann man sich nicht beschweren, das hat er gut gemacht.
Moina, du solltest vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt...
Das ist die Zarya one-on-one.
Gleich wird er da.
Fuck.
Genji ist down.
Das Dümmste, was dir passieren kann, ist, wenn deine Teammates auf der rechten Seite stehen,
alle Gegner auch rechts stehen und du hast als Widowmaker dann keinen Klingel mehr.
Wer hat dich gekillt? Der Genji, ne?
Genji ist hochgeflitzt.
Zarya ist long.
Ich habe gleich Ulti.
5%.
Okay, wir wollen anscheinend hier durch.
Nice.
Lucio ist weg.
Die anderen werden dich bestimmt sleepen.
Soll es aber...
Da geht er down.
Der gute Scientist.
Genji links.
Ich glaube, der will zu dir.
Fuck, was soll denn das für ein Sprung?
Hello.
Genji ist am Hellsperk rechts.
Woah, oi, oi, oi.
Jetzt wollten sie es aber echt wissen.
Nice, nice, doll.
Ich kann mal regroupen.
Ulti hätte ich besser ersetzen können.
Pings leapt.
Nein! Ich bin ein Dabby, ich bin ein Dabby.
Hast du dich selbst erschossen?
Ja.
Wir sind halt einer down. Eigentlich sollten wir jetzt noch gar nicht pushen.
Ja, oder die Mercedes hätte ich erst handhaben müssen.
Alter, das ist der...
Ja, ich werde jetzt vorn gehandelt.
Boah, ich habe die richtig schön gefeeldet, die Zarya jetzt.
So wie man es nicht macht.
Nice, nice pick. Go, go.
So, ich bin mir beim Crosshair voll drauf, aber es trifft mich.
Genji ist fast down.
Ich bin auch weg.
Außen weg.
Nein!
Fuck.
Zarya ist fast tot.
Hä, boah, sie hat getroffen.
Lol, Alter.
Auto wieder am Start.
Nein, das war Fail.
Das war... Oh, war das schlecht.
Oh Gott, war das schlecht.
Das habe ich so verkackt, ey.
Pff.
Round.
Locked.
Das habe ich richtig...
Richtig verkackt.
Ich hatte auf die andere Seite fliegen müssen und da die Bombe reinsetzen.
Nicht so eine Kacke.
900 IQ Old, ja.
Warum haben wir das überhaupt verloren?
Also, wir haben ja eigentlich schon alle Blood gehabt.
Oh, das war schlecht.
Hm.
Seid ihr in der Craft verreckt?
Ich nicht, aber die Leute.
Ah, da hätte ich den Genji gekillt, der war so low.
Ja, super.
Die machen gerade nichts anderes, außer sie zu handeln.
Ich muss was anderes nehmen, als D.Va, das klappt nicht.
Ja, ne.
Ich bin gerade Tracer.
Jetzt soll ich D.Va bleiben.
Ich fühle mich nicht effektiv als D.Va gerade.
Vor allem gegen die Zarya.
Ja, guck, der Roadhog dürfte auch nicht so effektiv sein.
Jetzt haben wir ganz halt Picks.
Freie Picks.
Rauf auf den Kackpunkt.
Hopp.
Rein da.
Uuuuuh.
Wieso?
Seit wann kann man denn nicht durch Gegner durchblinken?
Rutsch.
Wo ist die Ana von denen?
Ana hinten, solo auf dem Spot.
Wollt ihr in die Zarya reingehauen?
Ok, komm jetzt.
Ein Fight gewinnen und gut ist.
Ne, bin in den Roadhog, glaube ich auch nicht so gut gegen die.
Ich muss einfach gucken, dass ich nicht die Zarya immer die ganze Zeit anschieße.
Was ich ja mache.
Recruit.
Leute, recruit einfach.
Kein Sinn jetzt da vorne. Och.
Ey, ich werde die ganze Zeit von unsichtbaren Wänden aufgehalten.
Die ganze Zeit.
Fuck.
Soldier haben wir.
Tracer ist noch am starten.
Die kommen nochmal.
Oh.
Also Leute, die Runde ist echt keine Glanzleistung.
Aber...
Sollen sie sich von mir...
Du machst das ja gut.
Ohne dich hätten wir das ja nicht gewonnen.
Also ich spiele auch gerade wie so ein...
Ich habe jetzt wieder das Problem, was ich am Anfang auch hatte, als wir angefangen haben.
Ähm.
Da ich voll überfordert bin so wieder, was machst du jetzt, was machst du jetzt, was machst du jetzt.
So, Sniper-Time.
Da stimmt gerade eh was nicht.
Ich habe zweimal geblinkt und zweimal gegen eine unsichtbare Wand gekracht.
What the fuck.
Ich habe es gesehen, rechts beim Health-Pack.
Einmal Hingste.
Die... die... Tracers hinter uns.
Halt hier, einer Counter-Swipe.
Mich werde schädlich, da umgekehrt von beiden.
Mercy ist weg.
Alter.
Wo sind denn alle?
Moin, Mirrors, mein.
Fuck.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass alle tot sind.
Sonst hätte ich mich schneller gewiped.
Rechte Seite, rechts.
Das wird fix schmecken.
Fuck.
Wir machen da gefühlt gut Damage.
Ich habe jetzt Ulti.
Also vom Damage merke ich nichts hin.
Also willst du nicht, wenn man gefühlt ganz gut Damage.
So, jetzt mit Ulti rein nochmal.
Jetzt muss ich... Huge Ult muss jetzt.
Tracer fickt uns.
Damn.
Wo ist die Tracer?
Ich höre links irgendwas.
Ja, links tracert es sich.
Oder rechts jetzt? Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich habe das... Flash... geflasht.
Haben wir keine...
Nee, haben wir nicht.
Scheiße, ey.
Wie gerne hätte ich den Draft, man.
Ich bin auf dem Punkt.
Es gibt Sonnet.
Was ist eigentlich für ein komischer Spawn gerade?
Okay, wir sind wieder da.
Ich höre links irgendwas.
Der Reinhardt ist wieder da.
Die Mercy muss weg.
Ich treffe nichts heute, ey.
Ist ja ein Wahnsinn.
Alter.
Nice gecarried, ey.
Das war echt nichts.
Ich komme gerade auch nicht klar.
Boah, war das shaky. Das war ja grausam.
Da ist einer rumgezittert.
Bin ich im Teamchat? Doch, doch. Ich war im Teamchat.
Teammercy. Huge, huge Rats.
Huge Rats.
DPI und Zenz, probiere mal Ausrufezeichen Zenz.
Ich habe ein Kommando hinzugefügt.
Das müsste funktionieren, sonst habe ich den Nightbot irgendwie kaputt gemacht.
Probier mal Zenz.
Nee, außer so hinzugefügt.
Ja, funktioniert.
Everything objective time.
Weeey, 3600.
Aber heute, ne? Winning Stream angekündigt und schon Winning Stream.
Ist ja psychologische Sache.
Wenn man Losing Stream ankündigt, lust du wahrscheinlich.
Das musst du da...
Psychologisch, musst du da taktisch rangehen, ja.
Wobei ich habe gestern oder so exklusiv geguckt.
Hat auch fett Winning...
Äh, Climbing Stream.
Im Titel stehen gehabt und hatte dann, irgendwie ein paar Stunden nachdem er angefangen hat, 0,7.
Das war halt...
Das war halt die Grippe.
Wollen wir kurz Pause machen?
Wieso, Pause?
Nee.
Ich dachte, du willst irgendwie...
Also ich...
Können wir hier kurz stoppen.
Einmal auf den Block rennen und dann...
Weiter.
Alter, meine Katze stinkt.
Wie darf ich das jetzt verstehen, FiveEddy?
Und vor allem, warum gehst du auf Twitch und es im Chat jetzt uns mitzuteilen?
Was steckt da dahinter?
Gestus.
Genau so ist es.
Alle schreiben sich immer Voice-Chat, Team-Voice, sonst was und dann kommt nix oder geflame.
Oh, Opossum-TR ist richtig oldschool mit Turbo-Icon.
Juchux.
Komm jetzt.
Speed.
Heute noch gar nicht los Jux-Spiel.
Das machen wir jetzt.
Ach, warte mal.
Wir sind die Fans.
WTF.
Äh.
Juchux.
Oder ich mach zweiten Support.
Geht auch.
Gucken wir mal.
Komm.
Wir...
Ich...
Spiel trotzdem mal Lucian.
Hab ich bin auch drauf.
So ein gut Kompromiss aus Nerven und sogar ganz gut Heilen.
...Wie lange bleibst du bis gestern on?
Nachts ist kälter als draußen.
Oder was?
Was ist das für ein Satz?
Ich war noch nie draußen.
Stirbt man da wenn man raus geht?
Oder ist da irgend wo man mal aufpassen muss?
Weil, ich will jetzt nicht weitern...
Ne, man fliegt.
Man fliegt.
Hey, wenn wir jetzt eine Map auf dem Mond haben, dann müssten wir so Gravitationsspiele rein einbauen, aber ihnen ist wahrscheinlich ums Verrecken nichts eingefallen, wie man das ins Gameplay integrieren könnte.
Dann haben sie es außen gemacht.
Bestimmt würde auch, bestimmt würde auch.
Und bestimmt irgendwas schneiden.
Fahrer? Okay.
Oh, und Schneider. Okay.
Unten links, Soldier.
Unten D.Va.
Nein, mach den Soldier weg.
Ja Mercy, du sollst da vielleicht nicht alleine.
Soll ich dich abholen? Ich kann dich abholen, die sind alle tot.
Jo.
Ich soll fragen, passt das hier?
Die müssen es einfach nur verzögern.
Massive Teamplay, massive Teamplay.
Huge Teamplay.
Wo ist der Schneider?
Nein, nein, nein.
Hier, nimm das Ding.
Ah ne, ist gehackt. Gehacksort.
Ist von uns gehacksort, von uns gehacksort.
Wir müssen zum Spot.
Kacktum, Fist.
Reinhard,
mach doch dein Schild mal vorne hin.
Wo ist, wo ist denn der Sniper?
Keine Ahnung.
Wir müssen auf den Spot.
Soldier, Soldier, Soldier.
Ich bin bei dir.
Soldier hinter dir.
Widow oben rechts, oben rechts.
Beziehungsweise von dir oben links.
Im, im Technikraum da.
Callouts overwatch, null.
Gleich Ulti, gleich Ulti.
Pass auf, pass auf.
Nicht.
Egal.
Wenn die reinkommen, wird geultet.
Ich muss warten, dass ich nicht zu früh ulte.
Soldier ist oben rechts.
Ich hab Speed an.
Mercy, Murky.
Oh, oh, fuck.
Sag, wenn du gespawnt bist, vielleicht...
Ne, ne, ne, ich kann dir nicht helfen, komm.
Leute, wo seid ihr denn?
Alter, wo seid ihr denn alle?
Die Iris.
Oh, das ist ein...
Geballt.
Ich find's schade, dass die Leute mittlerweile so passiv geworden sind.
Walle-Schiss.
Keiner drauf.
So ein richtiges, weiß nicht, Baby-Gameplay geworden.
Da muss gefistet werden.
Auch ohne Doomfist.
Oh, Doomfist, verpiss dich, Alter.
Doomfist ist noch oben drin.
Hinter, hinter mir, hinter mir.
Alter, Doomfist.
Ei, dieser Drecksjar.
Der ist hinter, hinterm LKW links.
Man kann das blocken mit dem Schild.
Ist gar nicht.
Komm fort zum Healsorn.
Komm mal zurück, komm zurück.
Oben links ist wieder was.
What the fuck, meine Schüsse gingen einfach durch.
Was soll denn das?
Doomfist, kacke.
Wir müssen jetzt nicht sterben.
Weil die können nicht weiter pushen, wenn wir am Leben bleiben.
Ich bin bei dir.
Ei, dieser Drecksjar.
Doomfist, lull.
Wir sollten ein bisschen safe stehen.
Ich stehe gerade voll im Sichtfeld.
Hauptsache mal, Boop ins Nichts.
Alter, komm, komm, komm.
Los, bei Speed.
Oh, landet es.
Bei dir.
Den holen wir.
Ja, klar.
Rekt, Doomfist, rekt.
Keine Ulti mehr.
Pass auf, pass auf.
Fist.
Der hat gegen die Wand gefistet.
So wirklich koordiniert ist das auch nicht.
Wow.
Lull.
Das war Max-Range-Hook of Doom.
Okay, Ulti 20%.
Ich muss die jetzt irgendwie voll bekommen.
Alter, der verfickte Dreckslordhawk.
Der geht mir immer sowas auf den Piss.
Der hat dich gekillt, als er gestunt war.
Ist der Wahnsinn.
Ja.
Und jetzt lined ist der gelb.
Wo sind die?
Da ist der.
Ja.
Aber der ist echt drunter.
Und die hat einen Eingang.
Okay.
So, ich bin ziemlich sicher.
Wo ist der neue Eingang?
Gut, gut, gut, gut.
Und ich habe einen neuen Eingang.
Einen neuen Eingang?
Ja, der ist in den neighbouren Areas gegangen.
Oh, okay.
Unserer Eingang.
Okay.
Also.
Wir haben die neue Eingang gefunden.
Warte mal.
Was ist das denn?
Oh, kein Eingang, ne?
Oh, da ist der neue Eingang.
Woah.
Boop.
Bub ihn doch weg, du bist gestunt, nachdem du gehuckt wirst.
Also wenn du gehuckt wirst und one-shotted wirst, kannst du nichts machen.
Es sei denn, es killt dich nicht one-shot und erst danach kannst du buken.
Oder überhaupt irgendwas machen.
Oder shiften als Moira oder Wraithform als Reaper oder was auch immer.
Wenn er dich one-shotted, dann hast du gelitten.
Hat von euch jemand zufällig ein Aquarium und kann mir weiterhelfen?
Ich glaube, das ist hier der optimale Chat für alle Fischfreunde.
Hier ganz bestimmt ganz viele.
Aber ich kann ihnen leider nicht helfen mit deinem Aquarium.
Ja, Shaggar, in Silber klappt das meist, weil die Leute zu doof sind zu aimen und zu one-hitten.
Es ist aber schwierig, aktuell mit Drotter-Konsistenz zu one-hitten.
Also die meisten Targets, die meisten bisschen dickeren Low-HP-Targets,
kriegst du mit Hook, Schuss, Mele kaputt.
Aber auch nicht so richtig konsistent.
Ich sprech Nahkampf-Mele aus.
So wie Mehl.
Weißt, dass man das nicht so ausspricht.
Who cares?
Äh, Melee, könnte man ja auch sagen.
Ja, Leute, Leute, es kommt keiner, es kommt keiner, es kommt keiner.
Ja, das dachte ich auch, es kommt aber keiner.
Ja.
Der Doomfist will fisten.
Das war ja mal der lächerlichste Angriff aller Zeiten, ne?
Melee.
Mele, ich bin für Mele.
Mele ist feste.
Mit Fabian bin ich mir einig.
Das heißt Mele.
Nice, wir haben Pick.
Leute, move, move, move.
Ich krieg Anfälle.
Jetzt werde ich gefisst.
Warum moven wir da nicht?
Ich krieg übelste Anfälle.
Ja, das regt mich auch gerade auf, ey.
Das ist...
Wir haben sogar ordentliche Picks.
Was?
Oh Gott.
Okay, okay.
Also, wenn die jetzt nicht reingehen, dann kotze ich.
Nee, ich geh jetzt rein.
Egal, ob die reingehen, ich geh jetzt rein.
Easy.
Speed boost.
Ration.
Easy win.
Tracer slow.
Mele.
Haben wir Mele, haben wir die Tracer.
Wieso contesten die das so spät noch?
Wir können, wir können jetzt direkt durchgehen.
Oh, fuck, Altenkor.
Doomfist, verpiss dich, du Drecksheld.
Dieser Sch...
Alter, Doomfist.
Okay, Ulti ist raus.
Mein Ulti ist gleich da.
Jawoll.
Pick, pick, pick.
Wo ist die Tracer?
Speed.
Die ist weg.
Mercy slow, Mercy slow hinten.
Das war kacke.
Der hat mich weg, weggefistet.
Mir ist die Tracer.
Wo ist die Tracer?
Speed.
Die ist weg.
Mercy slow, Mercy slow hinten.
Das war kacke.
Der hat mich weg, weggefistet.
Mir ist die Tracer.
Das war kacke.
Der hat mich weg, weggefistet.
Meteor Strike.
Übrigens mein Fail, dass ich den bei Mcquee rausgeboopt hab.
Kann jetzt was dauern gehen?
Hack.
Wir müssen das haben.
Nein, ich...
Piss dich, Ohtok.
So.
Ätzend.
Der Beat vor ihm.
Lucio springt hoch, wird gefistet beim Springen und fliegt fünf Meter hoch.
So.
Fünf Meter nach hinten und trifft dann das halbe Team.
WP Lucio.
Äh.
Okay.
Ich hab's gerissen.
Offensichtlich.
Auch wenn mir das nicht so bewusst war.
Wahnsinn, ey.
Ich dachte diese Halb-AFK Torbjörn Plays wären gefixt.
Ist doch gut für uns.
Wenn sowas Play of the Game ist, dann haben die sonst nicht viel auf die Reihe gekriegt.
So, mal gucken, wie viel es jetzt gegeben hat.
Das hat auch mein Fünffach-Hedgehog durchüberschrieben, ne?
Ja, das sagt nichts.
Nimmst du auf gerade?
Äh, nein.
Ich glaub nicht viel.
Zwar ein Sprung durch.
Ich hör, es will gerade nicht laufen.
Okay.
Mal was gucken.
Ähm, Leute, hab ich...
Hab ich das Game davor schon eingetragen?
Als Win?
Ja, ne?
Wir sind jetzt bei 5-0.
Easy.
Next?
Jojo.
Bei wie viel bist du eigentlich schon?
Aber ich guck mal.
Ja, ne?
Wir sind jetzt bei 5-0.
Easy.
Next?
Jojo.
Bei wie viel bist du eigentlich schon?
Aber ich guck mal.
Ja, ne?
Alter.
Na gut, einmal minus 50 Telekom, ne?
Ja, aber trotzdem hab ich dich schon...
Danke Telekom.
... sind ja schon über 100 Punkte Abstand.
Ja.
Und du musst überlegen, ich war ja 100 niedriger als du.
Du warst niedriger, ja.
Schreckt?
Ist ja noch Performance-based, das heißt du performenst einfach.
Mhhhm.
Was du ja auch machst, ist es ja nicht.
Bei reinem Win-Loss
hätte es das nicht gegeben.
Aber gestern an der Runde
mit Reaper Lucio
hat man richtig gesehen, dass einfach
Performance-Based nicht funktioniert in dem Game.
Moin, little Samsung.
Top 500, Inka.
Das dauert noch ein bisschen.
Das dauert noch.
Torpion-Skill-Camp.
Jo.
Da kannst du nochmal Speed spielen.
Select your view.
Garden.
Robby, mach's mal.
Na, wie läuft's? Läuft gut, 5-0.
Oh.
Krassen Widow-Plays.
Komm jetzt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Heiler-Team
aus...
Soll ich...
Ich mach hier.
Mercy-Main.
Dass das andere
Pre-Made-Team sich nicht dazu
bewegen möchte, hier ein Tank
zu machen.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Overrated.
Wir machen jetzt unsere
besten Strats hier.
Damage boost.
Ist Zen eigentlich noch nicht spielbar? Ja, Zen ist
zur Zeit so der zweite Meta-Support.
Nebar, Mercy.
Nein.
Zweiter Schuss. Fuck. Zweiter Schuss
verfehlt.
Ich muss mal heilen.
Mercy low.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung.
Genji hüpft hinter uns.
Ich nehm ein.
Es ist außer mir noch keiner da.
Äh.
Hä?
Es ist gar keiner raus.
Ach doch, es ist einer raus.
Der ist raus und wir rein.
Blizzard, please.
Das ist seit Season 1 so.
Das ist so erbärmlich.
Eine Minute mitten im Game.
Das ist so lächerlich.
So
6-0, easy
Das zähle ich jetzt einfach als Win
Fertig
Kein Bock
Kann ich queuen?
Oder willst du kurz Pause machen?
Äh, kurz Pause
Okay
Leute, ich zähle das als Win
Das sehe ich nicht ein
Zumindest, wenn es schon nicht ingame als Win zählt
Dann können wir es wenigstens als Win zählen
It's win, it's life
So sieht es aus
Bis gleich
Ich verstehe nicht, warum das immer noch ein Ding ist
Das ist seit Season 1 so
Oder ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es sogar in der Beta schon so war
Ich glaube, das war sogar in der Beta schon so
Das war glaube ich in der Beta schon so
Ich kann mich da nicht mehr dran erinnern
Aber ich glaube, da gab es schon Posts, wo sich die Leute drüber aufgeregt haben
Wie kann das sein, nachdem quasi schon
Das ist ja auch so auf
Auf Numbani zum Beispiel
Wenn du da den ersten Punkt schnell verlierst
Sagt dann irgendwie auch noch, nö, ich liebe und scheune wieder rein
Ich werde euch jetzt nicht erklären, wie das funktioniert
Weil einfach mit Liebe
Und Scheune ist es nicht getan
Aber das ist lächerlich
Schon den Zen-Buff auf dem PTR gesehen
Was ich gesehen habe, ist, dass Zen jetzt so einen
Können wir uns ja mal zusammen angucken
So eine Anzeige hat
Orb-Targets
Wie viel Leben die haben
Meinst du das?
Können wir uns mal zusammen angucken, finde ich eigentlich ganz gut
Meinst?
Zeig es euch
OBS
Display Capture
Hier guck
Da sieht man Zenyatta-Harmony-Orb
Da guck
Das ist jetzt neu bei Zen auf dem PTR
Und wenn er Discord-Orb drauf macht
Discord-Orb?
Moment, wie heißt er?
Wie heißt denn der Orb nochmal?
Harmony-Orb und?
Heißt das nicht Discord?
Bin ich gerade verwirrt
Wie der Damage-Orb heißt
Discord, ja
Ich war gerade nur verwirrt, weil ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist
Ich habe mal Discord auf, habe ich gemerkt, hieß das wirklich Discord oder sage ich jetzt nur Discord, weil ich hier Discord offen habe?
Das
Was soll das?
Aber zumindest das ist jetzt neu
Das finde ich gut
Das sind so Kleinigkeiten, wo ich mir denke
Warum gab es das nicht schon schneller?
Aber ich will ja nicht so sehr drüber meckern
Ich bin ja froh, dass es sowas gibt
Aber das finde ich ist eine coole Sache
Ob das jetzt ein wahnsinniger Buff ist, kann man sich drüber streiten
Es ist eigentlich eher nice to have
Es ist nice to have
Wenn man jetzt sagt, hey man spielt mit Absprache und so
Dann ist das ganz cool
Dann rennt ein Target um die Ecke
Und du kannst sagen, ja okay, Genji ist um die Ecke
Hat nur noch, keine Ahnung, 10%
Ist fast tot
Dann hilft das was
Also ich würde sagen, das ist so
Eigentlich hauptsächlich wird eben jemand im Chat geschrieben
Quality of Life
So die Schwelle zwischen Quality of Life Change zu Buff
Und dann ist das so
Aber ich finde, es ist eine coole Änderung
Es gibt ansonsten so Neues in der Welt von Competitive Overwatch
Was sind denn hier so die neuesten Gerüchte?
Zeig mal her, kann man doch mal gucken, bis der E-Ax wieder da ist
Was hat ein Exklusiv wieder angestellt?
Was, was hat ein Exklusiv wieder angestellt?
Exklusiv Band
Was?
Machen sie wieder Exklusiv Hexenjagd, die Leute, oder was?
Reddit-Leute sind die Schlimmsten
Das sind so die, die die ganzen Justice Warrior
Selbst nichts geschissen kriegen
Aber bei anderen, die das nicht machen
Wenn man sich mal überlegt, was Exklusiv für eine Belastung ausgesetzt ist
12 Stunden gestreamen morgens und abends
Plus Grimms
Der macht ja nichts außer Off-Award spielen und pennen
Ja, und dass man da manchmal ein bisschen stinkig ist auf das Game
Kann ich voll und ganz verstehen
WB
Kann starten
Jupp
Ich schalte wieder um
Discord, zack
Q
Anubis, jawoll
Endlich
Ich hab schon drauf gewartet
Komm, Speed, go, go
Volle Pulle rein
Weißt du, ich hab eigentlich schon seit wir heute angefangen haben
Hab ich mir gedacht
Wann kommt endlich meine Lieblings-Map
Und jetzt ist sie da
Magst du eigentlich Max?
Ich finde, du wärst so der Typ dafür
Warum bin ich der Typ für Max?
2CP, lol
Das musst du mir jetzt erklären
Oh, wir haben ganz gute Setup
Natürlich, weil du ein Trending-Technik-Hipster bist
So ist es, so ist es
Leaked
Jetzt ist es raus
Busted
Exposed
Max-Exposed
Trending-Technik-Hipster
Also, Macs sind von der Hardware her tatsächlich nicht übel, ne?
Also, ich hätte nichts dagegen, einen Mac zu benutzen
Komm, Speed, go, go
Volle Pulle
In your face, die sind out of position
Diva steht unten
Die wird jetzt gereckt
Rektorino, Diva
Diva out of Mac
Zack
Fuck, ich bin nur...
Zen links, Zen links
Okay
Werden wir jetzt ab...
Nice, Pix, nice, Pix
Wir regroupen jetzt und kommen wieder richtig fett mit Speed
Ich versuche, dich zu safen
Nope, mach ich nicht
Wir kommen jetzt richtig fett mit Speed
Fett Speed-Boost kann man da jetzt rein
Ich warte noch auf dich kurz
Zumindest, wenn du mit Speed aus dem Spawn kommst
Und jetzt gehen wir voll rein
Wir gehen volle Pulle rein
Die sind nämlich noch auf dem Weg
Hierher
Oh, go, go
Go, Leute
Warum macht ihr das ewig rum?
Okay
Das ist total gesplittert
Nice, nice, nice, Pix
Very nice
Ich hab halt nur 5 HP, ey
Äh, ich geh nicht...
Oh nein, Leute, Leute, Leute
Ich bin gleich wieder da
Haha
Da winsten
5 HP
Die wollen es aber echt wissen
Die wollen echt...
Wir gehen direkt durch
Direkt weiter
Oh
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh
Rein, rein, rein, rein, rein, rein, rein, rein, rein
What the hell?
Was ist das für ein Kampf am ersten Punkt?
Das ist der Wahnsinn, wie lange das geht
Was geht da ab, ey
Aber die haben alles raus an Ultimates
Wenn wir was haben konnten, geht's was
Aber wir haben nichts
Oh
Auf, Jungs, volle Pulle
Gebt alles, gebt alles
Spiderman
Spider-Man, Spider-Man, Spider-Man, ganz viel Spider-Man, Spider-Lucio, sag mal, Leute, geht halt auf den verfackten, verfickten Punkt, weißt du, ich spring da drei Stunden in den schon rum und die Leute so, jetzt könnten wir mal vorgehen, need healing, need healing, ja, Kollege, das war, wie sie schneller reingehen sollen, kannst runterhüpfen, dann wirst du geheilt, gekillt, nice, da sei es hinterher, follow up,
go, go, Jungs, go, go, ich hab da wieder Ult, ich lenke den Soldier ab, der will mich, fuck, fuck, fuck, no, kurz vor Ult, man hört Soldier69 nicht, der sagt auch gerade nichts, wenn er was sagt, dann hört er ihn wieder, jetzt habt ihr gehört, oder, heal, ja, das war das Beste zu sagen, ne, ich quieke hier wie so ein Schwein,
puh,
ach, die Mercy ist ja gar nicht da,
oh, Winston, Winston,
okay, okay,
go,
Attacke,
ich tötz,
wo sind sie denn,
pass auf, Genji kommt zu dir hoch,
okay, vielleicht hab ich das ein bisschen falsch eingeschätzt,
der Grappling Hook hat einfach abgebockt,
ach, guck,
also, das ist ja eines der chaotischsten,
das ist ja nicht so,
das ist eines der chaotischsten,
2CP-Matches, das ich je hatte,
das ist ein verfickter Endpunch,
okay,
jetzt, Jungs,
oh, es ist einer tot,
ich hab gleich wieder Ulti,
ich hab gleich Sound Barrier,
nice,
oh,
drei Sound Barriers zum Schluss,
das ging ab,
das war eines der wirrsten 2CP-Rundaner-Zeiten,
das war eigentlich
von Anfang bis Ende ein Fight, oder,
gefühlt,
irgendwie schon, ja,
und da do off der
...
Littles Samsung, ja, da hast du Recht.
Ach, da, wer kommt mir der Name bekannt vor,
du hast mir mal ein Gameplay geschickt, ne?
Hab ich gesagt, du grindest zu wenig an den Wänden lang?
Ne, ich hab da den übelsten Spider-Man-Action gerade gemacht,
musst, du musst die Wände,
du musst ja keine halbe Stunde an den Wänden lang crinden,
Obama, Symmetra spielen.
Nee, das ganze
kriegt man, wenn die Gegner reindeifen, ist halt immer so
bäh. Dann, huge other plays.
Wird die Overwatch-School wieder
aufleben? Ja, wenn ich wieder besser bin.
Dann machen wir vielleicht auch mal
wieder ein paar Gameplay-Analysen.
Huge other picks.
Huge sleepdarts
kommen jetzt. Massive, massive sleepdarts.
Ich sag's euch.
Was ich jetzt oft gesehen hab, sind, dass da
oben, da wo du stehst,
die Widow steht, eine Orisa unten und macht
ein Shield hier oben vor die
Sniper und die Ds und steht dann
irgendwo an der Treppe hier rum, dass sie nicht getroffen werden kann.
Schaust dir das locker seit
fünf Jahren zu, siehst zum ersten Mal den Stream.
Ja, du kannst mir folgen auf Twitch.
Ich bin relativ oft online in letzter Zeit.
Eigentlich fast jeden Tag jetzt in den letzten paar Tagen gewesen.
Ist, ist, ist, ist das
Sniper-Action schon am Start?
Nice pick.
Haben die eine Widow? Ja, haben sie.
Achtung Winston, harambe.
Huge sleepdarts.
Oh, fuck, fuck, fuck, der Sleep, der ging in die Bubble.
Ich seh dich nicht.
Nice.
Mercy nicht peaken, nicht peaken.
Oh, ich werd gerest.
Huge rest.
Wo ist denn die Widow? Siehst du die?
Ey, hier, hier, flitzt
irgendwo eine.
Die Widow ist unten links.
Alter, meine Sleepdarts sind ja reudig gerade.
Mix mit Huge Sleepdarts.
Reinhard!
Alter!
Jetzt hitt ich mal einen und ich sleep mich selbst.
Ich hab meinen Anubus aufgehoben,
anstatt sie jetzt zu wasten am ersten Punkt.
Die war kein Mick.
Wir machen jetzt, wir machen jetzt
Huge, Huge 6-Minuten-Defense.
Pass auf.
Oh, ich seh dich.
Mercy, hüpf doch nicht so rum.
Out of Mag.
Was ist diese Scheiß Tracer?
Ich war gerade so auf dem Punkt.
Ich glaub, die ist rechts.
Ich glaub, die ist rechts hin in diesen Raum.
Da halt.
Was das heißt.
Wat?
Ich guck mal um die Ecke, ob die da rechts irgendwo rumgammelt.
Ja.
Die ist rechts.
Genji kommt rein.
Sieht aus, als hätte er ein Ult.
So, so, so, so.
NA Craft.
Sleep, sleep, sleep.
Hinter uns noch ne Affe, noch ne Affe.
Oh, ne Affe und ne Mercy.
Moin, XTP.
Soldier.
Da ist noch was hinten gewesen, oder?
Hab ich mich da verguckt?
Ne, wir haben beides.
Nice, nice, nice, nice Picks.
Huge Picks.
Fuck.
Huge Res.
Alles huge grade.
Massive, big, fat.
Gigantic.
Ich spam einfach mal.
Heal of the GZ.
Der ist an dir vorbeigesprungen.
Könnt ihr mal pushen?
Hopp.
Oh, bist down.
Ich glaub, du kriegst gleich nen Rats.
Soldier hat Weiser.
Der wird jetzt genano boostet.
Wo ist er denn? Da ist er.
Soldier, ich seh dich da noch net.
Fat sleep.
Okay, das war ein bisschen overkill.
Oh, ich bin gesniped. Oben links, Sniper.
Oh, Sherino.
Huge sleep.
Fuck.
Ich hab's nicht geguckt.
Ne, ich hab mich ja selber Instagram gegilt.
Schon wieder fast.
Pass auf, pass auf. Ich seh dich nicht.
Hier stehen so viele Leute vor dir.
Bist du wieder voll?
Ja.
Ich glaub, der ist fast down.
Ich hab gleich wieder...
Gleich wieder Dings hier.
Der Soldier hat auch Ulti, nice.
Huge.
So, wir haben auch nen Anubus.
Für den letzten Fight, falls die nochmal rankommen sollten.
Easy.
Easy win.
Jetzt kommt's.
Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding.
Wird erstmal verzwungen.
Ja.
Bling.
Bling. Wenigstens der Zweite, ja?
Ja, der Lucio ist auch noch mitgekommen.
Wenigstens der Zweite.
Du bist echt gut.
Auch wenn die Darts eher selten treffen, spielst du das sehr überlegt.
Dankeschön.
Ja, die Darts müssen noch ein bisschen genauer sein.
Aber ich übertreib's auch manchmal.
Ich versuch bei anderen meistens die total sinnlos schweren Darts,
anstatt auf das Ziel zu gehen,
was einfach zu treffen ist.
Oh, das gab ordentlich jetzt.
Hm.
Ja, gab das.
Der smurft ja auch.
Ich smurfe nicht.
Ich hab's seit Season 3 nicht mehr gespielt.
Und wieder einen neuen Account gewonnen.
Also ich find, das ist ein Unterschied.
Smurfen ist für mich jemand, weil man, keine Ahnung,
man spielt, man hat nen GM-Account und denkt,
hey, ich will jetzt mal ein paar Platts und Diamonds racken.
Das ist für mich Smurfen.
Nicht, ich hab ein halbes Jahr nicht gespielt,
mach mal einen neuen Account, dass ich wieder in das Game reinkomme.
Ich find, das ist schon so ein kleiner Unterschied.
Wo ist Mercy?
Ich hab noch nie Mainstream gekommen.
Mal gucken, ob wir das nachher wieder rausholen können.
Ich muss kurz Chat lesen,
dass ich mal wieder unten angelangt bin im Chat.
Kann ich mir den Kaffee machen?
Ja, klar.
Perfekt.
Dann mute ich mich kurz.
Viel Spaß.
Dann schau mal nicht lieber Adelaide zu,
der sagt huge alle paar Sekunden.
Ja, der übertreibt's.
Wobei, ganz ehrlich, dieses huge und massive
und dieses Gelabert,
da hab ich mich aus englischen Streams anstecken lassen.
Das ist, das ist schlimm.
Das ist echt schlimm.
Was auch, was ich richtig affig finde,
ist die ganzen Typen, die immer anfangen
my doggy.
Das hat irgendwie, hat xQcima damit angefangen
und alle sagen sie jetzt bla bla bla my doggy.
Das find ich total, das find ich richtig hängen geblieben.
Was ist das für ein Winstreak?
Das ist sogar noch
ein höherer Winstreak.
Was ist heute?
Viel Scootman Winstreak.
Eigentlich sind's
ja sechs, ne?
Das, das seht ihr auch, krasse mathematische Formel,
sieben mal sechs.
Eigentlich ist es
ja nur sechs, weil das eine Game war ja nur
fürs Gewissen, so.
Das war ja abgebrochen.
Warum bist du noch kein
Affiliate-Partner bei Twitch? Sollte doch schon funktionen.
Funktioniert schon seit,
seit Monaten, zeigt es mir an.
Willst nicht Affiliate werden.
Ich überlege mir vielleicht, vielleicht Partner zu werden.
Ähm, wenn sich da
die Gelegenheit ergibt.
Ich versuch jetzt aber erstmal hier ordentlich
bisschen Routine
reinkriegen in das Ganze
und dass ich so meinen Rhythmus finde
regelmäßig, weil, sagen wir mal so,
jeden Tag streamen krieg ich nicht hin. Vielleicht krieg ich das
jeden zweiten, jeden dritten Tag hin.
Muss ich mal gucken. Dann will ich auch
so, sagen wir mal so, die Viewerbase
ein bisschen ausbauen. Und dann
mal gucken, Partner.
Wer mich suppen will,
geht gerade nicht.
Aber wenn ihr mir doch irgendwie was zukommen lassen
wollt, könnt ihr auf der Profil, auf der Profilseite
auf den Donation-Link klicken und mir
was donaten. Aber, wie gesagt, ich bin froh
über alle, die zugucken. Es muss hier keiner irgendwie
was abdrücken oder so.
Irgendwie seltsam, obwohl Ranked so
scheiße ist, spielt, äh,
Max spielt wieder Overwatch, Killzen spielt wieder Overwatch.
Ist da was im Busch?
Wahrscheinlich hoffen wir alle drauf,
dass es demnächst ein Ranked-System-Rework gibt.
Und dann
vielleicht eine Team-Queue kommt oder
ob das dann das Ranked-System wieder
huge und geil und toll ist.
So, wir wollten uns ja mal die neusten
Overwatch-
Gerüchte und so angucken.
Was gibt's denn? Was haben wir denn hier?
Was ich Susie wieder angestellt habe, haben wir nicht rausgekriegt.
Ähm...
LittleSamsung sagt,
am besten ist es rein, einen Charge anzubieten,
wenn er ihn annimmt, ihm den Dart in die Fresse
zu hauen. Ja, oder was auch gut ist, einfach
durch das Reinhardt-Schild durchlaufen.
Was hältst du von Moira? Kaum gespielt.
Außer ein bisschen Quickplay.
Ich sehe noch nicht die krassen Moira-Comps,
aber warten wir mal die nächsten Pro-Matches ab.
Schon mitbekommen, dass die Amerikaner
Zeit...
Ah, ich hab Zeit...
Netzneutralität abgeschafft haben, laut
Zeit.de abgeschafft haben.
Ja, ich wusste, dass da irgendeine Abstimmung ist.
Ich hab drei Smurfs, Top 500.
Da bin ich wohl falsch mit Smurfen.
Jop.
Brauchst du
noch einen vierten Account?
Ähm...
Guckst du die dritte Staffel von MrRobot?
Ich hab noch nicht mal die zweite Staffel geguckt,
weil mich das Ende von Staffel 1 so enttäuscht hat.
Die letzten paar Folgen von Staffel 1 fand ich kacke.
Da ging es nur noch darum, was der Held für einen
Dachschaden hat.
Mit möglichst wenig Spoiler.
Jetzt versuche ich das mal.
Und die letzte Folge hat mich total enttäuscht.
Die ganze Serie arbeitet
auf so ein Ereignis hin,
was dann auch in der letzten Folge oder zwischen
Vorletzter und letzter Folge so passiert.
Und der Held verschläft es.
WTF? Was ist das?
Die erste Staffel habe ich mir nicht mal angeguckt.
Das Ende von MrRobot 1 hat mich echt enttäuscht.
So, was gibt's denn für neue Overwatch-Gerüchte?
Zeig mal her.
Ähm...
Rascal reported
XQC for throwing.
Aha.
XQC ist halt schon das Riesenthema hier
auf Overwatch heute.
Jedenfalls die Leute auf der Pressekonferenz.
Juckt mich nicht.
Wir müssen eh warten, bis Eax
wieder da ist, dass wir weiter queuen können.
Braucht jedes Team Psychologen.
Äh...
Ich glaube nicht, dass jedes Team Psychologen braucht,
sondern einzelne Spieler, wenn sie das Bedürfnis haben,
einen besuchen sollten.
PTR-Update. Okay, was gibt's da Neues?
PTR-Update?
Ja, das kennen wir schon. Das haben wir doch eben schon gesehen.
Gibt's sonst noch irgendwas?
Das ist echt ein Problem.
Es gibt viel zu wenig...
Es gibt viel, viel, viel zu wenig
Turniere in Overwatch.
Eigentlich müsste Blizzard ein großes Interesse
daran haben, dass es Competition auf allen
Level gibt in Overwatch.
Wer fängt an, Competitive zu spielen,
ist hier gleich der krasse
Overwatch-League-Owner.
Es müsste
Competition auf allen Level geben in Overwatch.
Und es gibt viel zu wenig Turniere.
Und es gibt auch viel zu wenig kleine Turniere.
Ich meine, da geht es nicht um die Platin-Turniere
oder sowas, aber es müsste Competition auf
allen Level geben. Nur das wird dazu führen, dass
Overwatch langfristig auch erfolgreich sein wird.
Aber mit dem E-Sport-Management
und der Geschichte von Blizzard...
Ihr wisst, dass ich da
nicht so zuversichtlich bin. Man guckt sich
mal an, was aus StarCraft 2 geworden ist.
Hast du Tipps, wie man im Rank schneller
hochkommt?
Was könnte da der beste Tipp sein?
Außer sich carryen lassen.
So wie mich
Eax carryt.
Was könnte
das Beste sein?
Also neben diesen Standarddingern wie natürlich viel
spielen, ist klar.
Ich glaube, das Wichtigste ist, dass man
sich selbst darüber im Klaren wird.
Oder dass man sich selbst
realistisch einschätzen kann.
Ich glaube, das ist das Wichtigste.
Nicht nur bei Overwatch, bei vielen Sachen
und bei vielen Games. Es hat keinen Sinn,
wenn man quasi nur sagt,
es liegt an den Teammates.
Das ist in Overwatch leider so.
Das Rankingsystem in Overwatch ist
absolute Grütze. Total beschissen.
Ja, das ist
Cancer und Tilt hoch 3. Aber
man muss sich selbst ganz gut einschätzen können.
Also sprich, es sind nicht immer nur die
Teammates schuld daran, dass man gewonnen hat.
Ich glaube, es ist wichtig, dass man selbst erkennt,
warum man Scheiße baut.
Und das sollte man sich auch eingestehen.
Wenn man Scheiße gebaut hat.
Weil nur dann wird man besser.
Ähm...
Übrigens, weil Leute vorhin nach
einer Sombra-Comp gefragt haben.
Gucken, ob es das auf YouTube gibt.
Dallas Fuel vs...
Fuck, was war das?
Was ist das Team von Mendo?
Wobei, waren die das?
Die haben nämlich Junkertown Sombra gespielt.
Das können wir uns mal kurz angucken,
was die für eine Comp gespielt haben. Was war denn das?
Dallas Fuel vs...
Gucken wir mal kurz.
Dallas...
Florida Mayhem, genau.
Florida...
Junkertown.
Achso.
Ich bin eigentlich bescheuert. Ich war gerade auf der
richtigen Seite schon und suche hier auf
Google rum.
Hier, erstes Match Junkertown war das.
Da hat Dallas...
Dallas Moira und Sombra und so
komische Dinger gespielt. War ganz
merkwürdiges Setup, was man so nicht
gesehen hat.
Wie ihr guckt.
Moira,
D.Va, Tracer,
Roadhog, Sombra,
Lucio.
Und nachdem es Dallas Fuel ist, sie haben sich
100 pro was dabei gedacht.
Ich kann mir da nur so ein paar Sachen auswählen,
wie nach dem Motto, Relativ Close Range
Tank, Relativ Close Range Tank,
bisschen Flanker Action und Moira kann halt
auch ganz gut diese zwei Tanks heilen.
Und...
halt auch gegen Bastion ganz gut.
Also so wirklich 100 pro
den
Geniestreich an dieser Comp, der ist mir
auch nicht ganz klar. Aber nachdem es Dallas Fuel
Ich meine, ich spiele ja auch nicht wahnsinnsweise
auf dem Level.
Nachdem es Dallas Fuel gespielt hat,
haben sie sich mit Sicherheit was dabei gedacht. Es ist aber
nicht aufgegangen. Sie wurden Hardcore
gereckt.
PTR. Gibt es PTR?
Other Changes.
PTR Change. Was gibt es denn da?
Oh nein, bitte nicht noch mehr Doomfist
Bugs. Bitte nicht
mehr Doomfist Bugs. Doomfist
ist jetzt schon absolut nervig
zu spielen und dagegen zu spielen.
So, ich bin wieder da.
Dann können wir ja...
Chat,
stimmt 7-0 oder habe ich irgendwas vergessen?
Ich glaube das stimmt. Ich glaube 7-0.
Du bist gemutet, falls du
was sagst. Ja, ich bin gemutet.
Es ist 7-0.
Ne, glaube ich jetzt. 7-0.
Wir haben 7 Games gemacht. Kommt das hin?
Zumindest haben wir nichts
verloren. Nichts verloren,
ja. Easy. Ich queue.
Oh, das geht. Jetzt holen wir
es gerade von Junker. Komm, Bastion Strats.
Ja, nicht schon wieder.
Defense.
Ich kann die
Defense Strats
nicht. Die Defense
Bastion Strats. Weiß nicht, wie das
funktioniert.
Haben wir Mercy Main?
Ich hoffe doch.
Nein.
Ah, ich brauche Healing. Das kriege ich doch nach Mercy Main.
Ne, sei ja.
Gar nichts.
Oh Gott.
Geh mal in Team Chat.
So, wer
vorhin geschrieben hat,
ich muss nochmal in diese Option. Man konnte doch irgendwie
ausstellen, dass man
mit Mercy immer zu dem Target
fliegt, wo man
den Strahl drauf hat. Weißt du,
unter welchen Settings das ist?
Das würde mich auch mal interessieren.
Das ist irgendetwas. Das geht.
Das habe ich letztens irgendwo gelesen.
Das muss ich ausschalten.
Toggle Beam Connection.
Wo ist das? Controls?
Yep.
Und muss man
Mercy auswählen?
Guardian Angel Prefers
Beam Target Off.
Jawoll. Nice.
Weil dann kann ich nämlich zu jemand anderem fliegen
und weiter heilen.
Das muss ich mir noch merken für meinen Main Account.
So, jetzt könnt ihr wieder
Huge Mercy Plays sehen.
Ich gehe mal oben
drauf.
Rektorino. Lol.
Das Schild ist auch versetzt für die Bastion.
Sag mir nur Hilfe.
Tracer von hinten.
Hilfe.
Der Fire Strike.
Fuck. Ich war auf dir drauf.
Oh oh.
Piss dich.
Du bist wieder vorne in Distigation.
Sonst staggert ihr.
Ach, wir staggern.
Ich bevorzuge zu staggern.
Ich finde das ist besser.
Nein.
Fail.
Oh, die gehen nochmal
zum Contesten.
Okay, dann ziehe ich dich vor.
Scheiße.
Die gehen nicht mal zum Contesten.
Ja, hat zu lange gestaggert.
Ich habe den Reinhard hier.
Wo bist du?
Ich habe den Reinhard hier bei mir.
Ich weiß nicht wo du bist. Wo bist du?
Mach da oben.
Warte mal, ich komme mal zu dir hoch.
Kannst mich hochfliegen lassen?
Passt, passt, passt.
Die haben die Bastion Strats nicht so richtig drauf.
Ich glaube die will zu mir hoch.
Fuck.
Zieh wieder hoch.
Leute, contested, contested.
Huge Mercy Plays.
Ich habe klar Ulti.
Ich bleibe mal auf dir
mit Beam.
Gucken wir mal, dass die nicht unten durchflanken,
gleich hinter uns lang kommen.
Sniper?
Ja.
Ich muss aufpassen, dass ich hier nicht
in die Sonne laufe.
Ach komm ey, ich habe auch abgedrückt.
Fuck off.
Kannst du mich heilen?
Ich bin vorne bei der Diva.
Ich bin bei der.
Nein, sie wurde auch...
Fuck.
Oh fuck, ich habe keinen Ratz mehr.
Nooo.
Schon wieder ey.
Ich kann nicht gleich ratzen.
Sie nutzt halt den Crackling Hook nur für mich.
Mega ärgerlich.
Oh links, links, links.
Oh, oh, oh.
Nice, nice, nice.
Wir müssen jetzt ein bisschen...
Kenji.
Wir müssen ein bisschen zurück.
Ich komme zu dir hoch.
Komm da weg.
Ich muss die Diva heilen.
Ich muss zu dir hoch.
Fuck, das habe ich nicht.
Help Leute.
Ich kann nicht zu dir fliegen, das ist mein Problem.
Das ist egal.
Das ist so chaotisch.
Ich sehe nichts wegen dem Penisraiser.
Das war eine scheiß Ult von mir.
Wo ist denn der Verkackte?
Da ist er.
Oh, jetzt hat er eine Runde gezogen.
Echt?
Jutsch, Mercy Place.
Was ist das?
Plane der Chaar.
Du hast Damage Boost.
Kann ich, kann ich, kann...
Kannst du mich hoch...
Nein, nein, nein, ich muss hier unten drinnen heilen.
Äh.
Ich komme zu dir.
Kannst du die Diva nicht mitnehmen?
Da war ich natürlich wenig Einfluss drauf.
Beim nächsten Mal sagst du Bescheid.
Ich komme zu dir mit der geflashten Diva.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass die da ist.
Die haben keine Widow mehr.
Gott sei Dank.
Wo bist du? Kommst du vom Spawn, oder?
Ah, ne, du lebst noch.
Die Anna blockt.
Oh, Tracer, Tracer.
Oh, Rekt.
Hardcore Rekt.
Aber richtig gut gestallt.
Vielleicht kriegen wir das jetzt. Bashen, Bashen.
Anna, Jutsch, Place, Anna.
Nein, mit dem Chimecrack nicht.
Ich habe wieder Wald gehabt.
Shit.
Äh, nope.
Das war aber eine super Zeit für den zweiten Punkt.
Mhm.
Wenigstens steht keine Basher mehr auf der Payload.
Ich sehe schon mal was.
Nicht, dass die jetzt auf die Idee kommen zu switchen.
Oh, links, Roadhog.
Weißt du?
Ich versuche dich zu boosten.
Es soll bloß jemand den Chilldown machen.
Dann habe ich Impact.
Was geht denn da eigentlich gerade ab?
Tracer?
Oh, Leute.
Wo?
Noob! Mercy, Noob!
Voll reingeflogen.
Shit.
Der Junkrat trifft nix.
Trifft gar nix.
Suck Balls.
Auf, Leute.
Ich mache jetzt Jutsch, Jutsch, Jutschwärts.
Jetzt muss einer down gehen.
Ich kann das nicht.
Ah, ich wurde gefickt.
Der Junkrat kommt mit dem Tire.
Das könnte was werden.
Ich komme mal mit Speed wieder.
Was?
Nice, C9.
Ah, C9, sehr schön.
Das einzige, was er im Voice Chat gesagt hat,
die ganze Runde, war C9 eben, der Typ.
Richtig C9.
Do Orisa Bastion?
Komm, komm, wir machen die Bastion.
Bastion Strats.
Ja, ja, können die ja machen.
Ich lehne dann den Gegner ab.
Muss halt bloß nur rein.
Wir brauchen eine Mercy.
Aber ich Mercy.
Weil die richtig pro
Bastion Strats sind ja
Orisa plus Reinhardt.
Plus Winston. Nein.
Und Overkill.
Aber da kommt Defense Matrix noch dabei.
Ja, Moira macht schon ordentlich Damage,
aber das ist ja auch mit Konzept
von diesem Held, dass du ja
quasi so Mana-Ressource hast,
wo du healen kannst und wieder
Mana saugen kannst von Gegnern.
Also musst du
ein bisschen was machen.
AD Spam.
Ich brauche eine neue Tastatur, dass schneller AD Spam kann.
Ich booste mal
eine Runde am Anfang.
Boosterino.
Ja, guck halt, dass du mehr Fokus auf das
Thema hast, als auf mich.
Ja, am Anfang kriegst du jetzt erst mal.
Am Anfang kannst du jetzt erst mal schön alles schnipsern.
Moin, DarkFabzi.
Wo sind Genji und Jones?
Ja, Rechtsseite.
Oh, oh, oh.
Von rechts, äh, von links.
Irgendwo, irgendwas hat mich da gerade
Eis angehauen.
Oh, saug woanders dran.
Oh, oh, oh.
Von hinten, von hinten eine Mei.
Was?
Wieso hat das nicht getroffen?
Hä?
Die Mei ist immer noch hier hinten bei der D.Va im Haus.
Und, äh, hier
Tracer noch bei uns.
Moment, wir sind mega lang auseinander
gezogen. Irgendwo ist noch eine Tracer zwischen dir und mir.
Ja, bei mir.
Boom.
Direkt.
Bärschen oben rechts, ja.
Ich kann dich nicht boosten.
Au.
Ich seh dich schnell.
Ich geh.
Mei ult.
Tracer hinter dir, geh weg da.
Ich weiß nicht wo ich hin soll.
Pff.
Ne, ich kann nirgends wohin.
Die Tracer trifft aber nicht gut.
Ich bin noch nicht da.
Nice so, nice so, nice so, pick.
What?
Oh, merci.
Bisschen low.
Maybe at the point.
Mach doch mal die Mei tot, Leute.
What the fuck?
Gute Zeit, gute Zeit.
Könnte sein, dass die nochmal kommen. Zeit genug hätten sie.
Aber dann halt ohne Mei.
Wir brauchen uns nicht.
Kommst du hoch?
Hier lang.
Flieg.
Ich muss mal heilen hier hinten.
Ich hab Boost auf dir.
Ich muss heilen, ich muss heilen unten.
Pass auf.
Pass auf, die Mei ist noch oben bei dir.
Die Mei ist immer noch oben, oben bei mir ist die Mei.
Fliegst du von mir rüber?
Ich bin unten.
Okay, nice.
Mein besten Flank war Fail.
Ich guck mal ob ich den geretzt kriege.
Nein.
C9, auch gut.
Easy, easy win.
Was'n heut los?
Keine Ahnung, Winningstreak halt, ne?
Ab geht's.
Also ich weiß nicht was heut los ist,
aber
so'n krassen Winningstreak
hatten wir noch nie.
Ich muss mich mal
selbst liken.
Wegen den absoluten
Massive Mercy Plays.
Keiner liked mich.
Das 64
reicht auch nicht. Ja, das ist
nicht likewürdig.
Während es jetzt 64%
Crit Rate
Mal gucken wie viel es gab.
Naja.
2800 Punkt, genau.
Zack.
Was, warum?
Warum kriegst du so viel mehr?
Du bist jetzt 130, 138
Punkte schon drüber.
Ziehen wir mal 50 ab.
Trotzdem.
Ja, eigentlich so gesehen 238,
wie wir angefangen haben.
Ist der Wahnsinn.
TF, Fail.
Ich muss mal aufs Klo.
Ich würd fast sagen,
dass wir jetzt
Schluss machen.
Weil ich muss jetzt eh gleich
wunder Abendessen und Duschen
und Zeug machen noch.
Noch was aufnehmen.
Alles klar.
8 Games, Flawless
Victory Tag heute.
Huge Plays.
Übrigens Patrick, weil ich dich gerade im Chat sehe,
sorry, dass ich deine Donation nicht gesehen hab letztens.
Der alte Max hätte 10-0.
Tja, kann ich alles haben.
Dafür gab's
huge Mercy Plays.
Und, ähm,
die Leitung ist nicht abgekackt
heute. Das scheint doch was mit
den Settings zu tun zu haben.
Bei mir ist auch nichts abgekackt.
Verwunderlich.
Oh.
Hm.
Wie macht man eigentlich Rates
in Twitch?
Ich hab keine Ahnung,
wie das funktioniert.
Ich hauste einfach jetzt mal irgendjemand.
Und...
Gut.
Vergiss deine Keks-Rate-Nachricht nicht, ne?
Ich weiß nicht, wie das geht.
Ich bin da viel zu noob für.
Gibst du im Chat
eine Nachricht? Keks-Rate?
Achso! Ja, ja, ja.
Ich, ähm...
Slash-Rate-Name. Und was passiert dann?
Opossum TS, was
passiert dann?
Kriegt der dann irgendwas angezeigt, oder was?
Ich hauste euch jetzt mal jemand.
Ich glaub, das ist ein Österreicher.
Allerdings macht der einen englischsprachigen Stream.
Super educational
Content.
Kabaji, glaube ich, spricht man ihn aus.
Guck ich immer gerne.
Hat auch einen YouTube-Channel.
Ansonsten, ich hoffe, euch hat der Stream gefallen.
Wer noch nicht
gefollowed ist, denkt dran,
das übliche. Like, subscribe, comment, donate,
follow Twitter, Twitch, Facebook, Instagram, Tumblr,
Snapchat, Patreon und Myspace.
Und macht's gut, bis zum
nächsten Mal. Tschüss.
Oh Mann.
Und gebt ihm mal mit die Message
Keks-Rate.
Bis dahin, tschüss.
Jetzt muss ich mal gucken.
So.
Es war nice heute, oder?
Ja, ging gut rein.
War echt sehr nice.
Ja.
Weil manchmal bin ich so ein bisschen enttäuscht.
Da könnte noch so viel mehr gehen.
Aber nee, geht einfach nicht so.
Es lief halt echt gut.
So, ich bin mal kurz noch im Klo.
Jo.